bonjour tout le monde
alors les premiers quart de finale je
viens de commencer je suis en train de
régler les caméras parce que
on vient à peine de recevoir tout ça il
y a eu des problèmes d'ordinateur avec
avec du coup Sarine encore une fois
donc je suis en train de les remettre en
place
qui oppose le prodige indien Miral
Sarine de 18 ans à
Digne-les-Bains qui peut faire office
comme de favoris ça reste un joueur
exceptionnel plus aguerri mais on sait
que Sarine est très dangereuse sur
Internet et puis il l'a déjà prouvé pas
plus tard que mercredi ou il avait battu
à l'arraché à nigéri un match que tu
avais commandé d'ailleurs
c'est ça et d'ailleurs c'est Kevin était
là j'aurais sûrement parié sur
suring quand même je préfère parier sur
en fait il est quand même numéro deux
mondial avec carvana ils se discute
vraiment pour la place du numéro 2
clairement et du coup perdu beaucoup de
points et de place c'est tout frais
récemment ouais mais depuis des années
c'est comme les pour moi les les deux
qui se battent pour la deuxième place
clairement pour moi c'est de meilleur et
même si bon il a été en méforme
dernièrement bon il va remonter je pense
voilà mais du coup ok Ding il est
vraiment impressionnant généralement en
speech et donc tout ce qu'on parle de
Blitz Bullet c'est pas vraiment c'est
cadence mais ils a quand même l'année
dernière vraiment surpris dans ses
matchs il avait failli battre la Camorra
et il avait fait de très très gros match
en tout cas très très impressionnant il
est capable
exceptionnel peut-être celui qui est
capable de mieux jouer aux échec avec
Carsen diminueren après ça dépend de sa
forme du jour aussi de l'horaire j'ai
pas quelle heure il est en Chine
toujours pareil avec ses matchs
fraîcheur des joueurs en tout cas on
voit direct les honneurs tous les deux
très concentrés avec caméra c'est ça
il a quand même 2800 € quoi c'est quand
même le numéro de mondial donc c'est
c'est vraiment un excellent joueur et ni
hastarine c'est aussi un excellent
joueur aussi mais bon il est il est il
est à peine dans le top 60 70 peut-être
mondial et il est encore jeune il est
bien sûr très talentueux il fait de très
très bon
résultat mais bon c'est vrai que dim
quand même est censé être être meilleur
être plus fort donc en tout cas un match
hyper intéressant
salut mala bienvenue à toi bienvenue à
tous ceux qui nous rejoindre petit à
petit on a un vendredi en début
d'après-midi donc c'est pas forcément
L'Oréal idéal pour que pour qu'on ait
foule pour ce match mais on essaiera de
vous le faire suivre au mieux en tout
cas
de finale et
dans un match d'ailleurs il y a des
petits soucis de connexion c'est aussi
toujours un enjeu souvent
qui a eu des problèmes de connexion OK
et l'iral on sait qu'il en a eu aussi
Mirac a l'air d'avoir une grosse grosse
cruciale
je vois ça et encore moi j'ai la caméra
en grand parce que j'étais en train de
régler les caméras les autres caméras
donc
voilà je suis en train de finir le
boulot parce que ça arrive a eu pas mal
de retard en fait si vous voulez
sur sur la conversation zoom
et du coup je suis en train de leur
caméra à côté pendant ce temps là
pendant ce début ça va prendre quelques
minutes ça ça arrive du coup c'est vrai
que on discute on n'a pas trop suivi
c'est une carotane qui a été jouée par
un c'est intéressant de voir que 10
villages E4 puisque 10000 il est
clairement capable de tout jouer il joue
beaucoup l'anglaise il joue du cavalier
F3 et je joue des 4 donc peut-être que
dans ce match il a préparé plutôt du E4
ouais après je pense que comme c'est un
joueur qui joue tout et ben il va
essayer de voir un peu voir enfin
peut-être sonder un peu
farine voir ce que ça rime après vu sur
tel ou telle ouverture
est-ce que tu sais justement si ça
arrive de la quarantaine c'est une arme
habituelle chez lui ou pas parce que moi
je connais pas son répertoire
je sais qu'il a il a joué contre Guiri
il a beaucoup joué contre guéri et
d'ailleurs c'était il y avait une
variante dans laquelle il avait surpris
guéri enfin deux fois d'affilée il a il
a obtenu de superposition
contre guéri et du coup pendant la pause
d'iris en pressé de se préparer de
vérifier ces lignes du dessus et la
revenue et là il a mis une grosse grosse
fessée à Sarine donc c'était comme ça
que ça s'est passé
donc
ça c'est vrai que c'est un joueur qui
normalement peut-être le mieux préparé
du circuit avec Caravana donc pas facile
de le prendre à partir dans les
ouvertures et donc du coup cette
première partie on voit que dylian il
n'y a quand même pas mal réfléchir on
commence on soigne plus jeune au nom
vous avez l'habitude du format donc au
début c'est un petit peu plus lent il a
quand même bien pris son temps le numéro
chinois ici
il prend son temps à la position qui est
qui est pas mal il y a une majorité ici
il a deux contraintes ce côté là et elle
contrôle du centre donc le cavalier
c'est important qui est pas forcément
bien placé le plan H5 qui est en prise
et je pense qu'il va essayer bon au fur
et à mesure de de passer un petit pion
d'être à 3 B4 ou peut-être
[Musique]
comme tu l'as justement fait remarquer
il est vraiment très moche
quand il y a un pion en G3 comme ça et
c'est valable bien sûr couleur inversé
se retrouve un petit peu un petit peu en
fait si tu perds juste à 500 rien faire
ça risque d'être compliqué pour toi
du coup la justification peut être
sacrifier la pièce ici à tous en sens
pour pas être juste ridicule à part ce
pion
il y a aussi tours C4 qui est
intéressant qui empêche d'apprendre H5
avec la prise du Fou et qui va permettre
à pression supplémentaire au pion H4
donc B3 je sais pas si ça nous aide
beaucoup ou pas ton B4 hein et F6
c'était aussi un des coups que je
regardais pour ouvrir la position ouvrir
la colonne 9 etter c'est vraiment le
coup qui était joué contre
la caméra sont là regarde c'est dix
Mirren qui avait blog je suis désolé
ouais je je vais pas changer la bonne
scène
je suis désolé
d'hier soir de Maca du coup d'un seul
coup on a l'impression que c'est un
petit peu plus lent ça lui Fatou salut
Fatou salut thé vert salut à tous salut
beaucoup plus rapide il y a le pion qui
est tombé
il y a un pion qui a été gagné un
paradis Rennes ici option gagné et il y
a la case 5 qui est une bonne case pour
les blancs mais attention quand même
contre j'ai cru et si c'est le pion B2
donc là faut éviter probablement et on
va jouer dame 2 je pense et peut-être si
on peut mettre un cavalier en Détroit et
fixer un peu la carte de 5 depuis on va
aussi ça peut être sympa pour les blancs
donc faut voir si vraiment il arrive à
stabiliser ça avec les Blancs s'il y
arrive l'avantage sera clairement pour
les blancs
parce que
sa position justement comme on en
parlait avait l'air compliqué il avait
un pion qui allait tomber en cavalier
mal placé alors certes il a perdu un
pion mais avec l'arrivée du fond F6
active bien il a aussi deux pions au
centre liés le cavalier en 1 et pour
l'instant encore un petit peu loin de
l'action
c'est pas si mal il y a clairement du
jeu après voilà ça dépendait ce que tu
arrives à faire avec le Centre parce que
si tu arrives à être mobile avec les
Noirs ça peut être intéressant soit le
pion arriéré qui est passé maintenant
assez assez incisif en 4 et là les Noirs
c'est vrai qu'ils ont pas mal de jeux
donc c'est quand même du problème
mais attention si jamais elle arrive à
consolider et à jour et un jour pousser
mes pions ça peut être pas mal les
cavaliers qui a du mal vraiment à
trouver une place où aller parce que sur
trois il pourrait se prendre un rendu D4
et sur cavalier F4 bah même il est pas
forcément très stable ici et même il
faut prendre un hashtag qui peut être
possible des fois donc intéressant
d'ailleurs Samy est-ce que tu veux
prendre un petit bête ou pas tu veux
mais je crois qu'on veut tous les deux
bêtes sur 10000 Rennes donc c'est
pratique ok alors si tu proposes un peu
intéressant je peux bête ça arrive hein
j'ai absolument aucun problème là-dessus
parce que en vrai elle est pas si si
loin à mon avis sur le papier encore une
fois on propose intéressant ça veut dire
que
ok toi comme tu le stream pas tu es pas
intéressé par les subs donc du coup
peut-être me trouver quelque chose
d'autre je sais pas un enjeu je sais pas
s'il y a des suggestions dans le chat
d'ailleurs est-ce que aussi dans le chat
vous avez un joueur favori entre les
deux ou pas on peut faire un petit
sondage après peut-être
avec trois temps un petit peu que les
gens arrivent peut-être
on a un problème justement entre angosu
pour le titre du stream c'est que on
n'avait pas accès au code de cheeseccom
fr
un bug en fait vous pouvez pas accéder
donc on ne pouvait pas changer pour
l'instant au titre on va voir si au
cours du stream ça évolue mais on est
bien en compte en amont pour l'instant
c'est bloqué
effectivement il ressemble nyanaka ni
apparemment ils ont pas tout à fait la
même tête d'ailleurs Naka qui fête
aujourd'hui c'est 35 ans bonaka il y a
un petit air avec dingue
je pense que c'est un peu les deux
personnalités opposées à mon avis
non mais bon ok
alors donc là il y a un de dame on
échange mais
bon je pense avoir comme favoriser
plutôt les blancs ici avec le rat noir
qui est un petit peu dans les courants
d'air tu vois sur Facebook
mais attention à pas à pas se prendre
trois qui pouvait être aussi un coup
enfin en tout cas une menace qui peut
arriver
ça y est on sait que dans cet exercice
cavalier fuite est une menace attention
et puis avoir des des maths
mais je doute que qui rentre quand même
là dedans à 10 minutes
à quelle vitesse il a vu cette petite
pirouette pour aller mater le roi et du
coup
c'est un bon début pour diminuer qui
marque les esprits d'entrée ouais 1-0 du
coup pour pour Ding
et j'avais tiré il a sonné enfin il a
fait sonner la sonnette d'alarme le
petit Ding a déjà pas déjà arrivé
j'essaie de voir si on peut changer le
titre de me renseigner mais
Arnaud comment tu vas
mettre Arnaud mettre un nom s'il vous
plaît
alors j'ai trois ok j'ai trois fougères
ça à peu près standard dans ces
positions alors souvent je viens de fou
ces quatre à la place de de G3 mais ici
en fait ils veulent souvent jouer contre
à la diagonale blanche souvent en fait
les lois veulent jouer
c'est quand même pas mal on va attaquer
du coup la diagonale Céline qui relève
le niveau des genoux
un gaz
non ça je le dirai pas ça je crois que
c'est plus c'est plus compliqué à faire
ce genre de blague je crois Cyril
ça passe pas toujours pas entre nous
mais bon la sonnette pour dingue bon
c'est mignon quoi
j'avais fait quoi hier j'étais assez
fier de moi
déjà je pense que c'est bien
de quoi ça peut vite être trop
seulement 12 minutes de live et ouais
est-ce que c'est une tour en prise Samy
ça d'un point à chacun qu'est-ce qu'il
veut faire est-ce qu'il compte faire
[ __ ]
j'imagine que il a pas inventé ça sur
l'échiquier en 4 secondes donc il a pas
mal regardé
cinq échecs
et aussi maths et ça la rupture a
empêché les deux
sept donc on peut pas vraiment parler
les deux tout simplement c'est pour ça
fait un truc comme ça parce que je peux
même pas manger parce qu'il ramasse en
fait je crois même pas la dame
intéressant ça arrive du coup tu manges
pas à la tour du coup il va jouer grand
rock et
ça peut poser des problèmes pratiques
diminueren qui réfléchit déjà beaucoup
donc il a pas l'air de connaître
donc il peut se permettre
mais
pas mal cette petite idée de dire salut
Marius château bienvenue à toi est-ce
que tu sais qui c'est Marius non
tu vas me la prendre du coup je le sens
à lui-même se présentait dans le chat
moi je sais qui c'est
non il veut garder le secret
ça sera ça prend au fil d'une enquête
[Musique]
c'est très tactique tout de suite ce qui
est plutôt le terrain de jeu de niram
normalement mais Ding t'as effectivement
il est quand même bon aussi il touche on
est d'accord ouais ça c'est clair
j'aime bien quand même l'idée de de
prendre et faire un rock j'ai
l'impression que j'ai beaucoup d'avance
de développement et qu'il y a beaucoup
de jeux quoi et quasiment
si le Fou vient à tomber j'ai
l'impression que c'est juste écrasant en
fait mais ça a l'air personnellement tu
vois enfin j'avance développement et
j'ai des menaces concrètes quoi
d'un projet 4 grands rock dame C6 j'ai
fougé deux qui est intéressant
et du coup il faut reculer la dame
et du coup je lui cavaler des dessins
enfin
j'ai vraiment l'impression que c'est que
c'est très compliqué pour pour les Noirs
ils ont toutes les pièces à la maison
une caniche qui prennent tant de temps
finalement à
la raison pourquoi pas la cadence le
permet mais
qui a froid
qui qui se met une petite petite veste
un petit sweat à capuche
et on précise
[Musique]
que je commente des événements avec à
chaque fois on se pose la même question
parce que
[Musique]
sa chambre ressemble à une chambre
d'hôtel
et
très impersonnels vers le tableau
derrière lui plutôt ça fait un peu
d'hôtel mais ça fait vachement
c'est ma valeur écrasant pour les blancs
mais la jauge qui redescend qui donne
avantage noir et du coup
c'est peut-être plus compliqué que ce
qu'on pensait mais ok là je pense à vous
deux
qui m'a l'air bien est-ce qu'il y a pas
un an il y a pas F50 parce que je pense
sur un chèque
là c'est un peu moins concret il y a
moins de menace l'impression à fougère
sur un coup d'accord j'aurais commencé
aussi comme toi peut-être parfois j'ai
deux mais
c'est 5 sûrement peut-être c'était le
coup qui empêchait jamais
4 B5
juste après besoin de de comprendre ce
qui se passe ah il y a faut acheter des
chèques qu'on a raté complètement et il
y a plus de masse ok on est juste nul
enfin je me déshydarise complètement
à la plage si tu me laisses j'aurais vu
bien évidemment vu faut agissent
intermédiaire tu peux quand même
donc commencez par cahier des 5 c'était
logique on a un supporter de 10000
Rennes qui profite du
fait que carcène est décidé de ne plus
défendre son titre et de me dire qui
affrontera un dépôt je crois que c'est
en avril 2023 pour voir la couronne
mondiale en classique c'est ça peut-être
le futur champion du monde auquel on a
affaire aujourd'hui
je t'annonce la bonne nouvelle que
Nathan a réussi
[Musique]
batailler pour changer le ce titre
les jetons je crois en machine je crois
que comment il s'appelle
par avion n'est peut-être pas envie de
prendre encore ça franchement
il était pas chaud pour revenir
aujourd'hui
fera-t-il bouger les choses bah il y
aura un nouveau champion du monde déjà
Lucas moi je pense que c'est moi
en terme de format je pense
que il y a des chances que ça change
façon maintenant avec les chèques sur
internet avec tout ce qui se passe je
pense que l'échec sur les cadences
depuis plusieurs années ça accélère à
chaque fois
et je pense que il y a un moyen de ça
change un petit peu parce que bon quand
même personne qui renonce la couronne en
vrai c'est niveau médiatique tout ça
c'est quand même pas forcément l'idéal
pour la fille c'est pas une très bonne
nouvelle quoi je pense et regarde comme
c'est mignon tu as un programme il y a
cavaler ses sept
il a bien bougé roi bien pas qu'il faut
H6 échec comme tout à l'heure
intéressante en tout cas c'est une
partie assez sympa et jolie c'est très
tactique
mais du coup moi je suis d'accord avec
parce que ben écoute
tout simplement
[Musique]
en vrai tactiquement
tactiquement il en a une belle
franchement
ça c'est aussi une caractéristique du
jour qui abandonne
mais il va beaucoup moins tenter par
exemple qu'on a qu'à de
d'arnaquer ou de sauver quand il est
foutu il dit bon bah ok l'autre ami
j'abandonne je passe à la suivante mais
non c'est clair donc ce match de 5 + 1
avec une idée très tôt de sacrifice dans
l'ouverture qui t'intéresse clairement
[Musique]
justement il sera tenté de repasser par
la route des candidats que les candidats
ça reste le tournoi le plus intéressant
à suivre le plus dur peut-être plus que
le un karmatch on lit même pour le titre
c'est pas ça dépendra certainement du
aussi des éventuelles changements de
format si car ça limite vraiment pour
qui est que ce soit un petit peu quelque
chose d'hybride t'inquiéter classique
mais aussi qui est des parties rapides
et que ça compte pour le même pour le
même titre
donc c'est difficile de savoir si ça va
évoluer en son sens ou non
mais
un peu marre aussi de franchement
peut-être si le champion du monde change
si c'est intéressant tu vois si on a on
a un jeune qui arrive ou quoi je pense
un peu le motiver un petit peu mais là
c'est une époque champion du monde je
doute que il fasse des califes pour que
je comprenais pas
c'est sûr qu'il se dépose à pas ça va
pas le motiver les masses
déjà c'est quelque chose de c'est un
nouveau joueur et c'est un genre un peu
ce que personne respectant énormément
donc ça peut peut-être
je croise les joueurs des fois il y a
des tournois ou leur pose des questions
un peu marrantes et je crois qu'il y en
a une c'était avec quel autre collègue
du haut niveau vous partiriez sur une
île déserte vous avez le choix et car ça
donne répondu 10000 Rennes donc ça
prouve aussi que vraiment il l'apprécie
qu'il le respecte voilà et pourquoi elle
avait ingueren est-ce qu'on sait
pourquoi il pensait que c'était le
joueur la personne au-delà du joueur la
plus intéressante avec qui c'était
coincé jusqu'à la fin de ta vie sur une
île déserte bah discuter et puis je joue
aux échecs j'imagine ok je pense pas
qu'il avait choisi sur l'aspect
peut-être le plus à l'aise pour survivre
pour
ceux qui veulent bouffer quoi
de respect pour pour lui ah oui non mais
c'est clair
c'est un super joueur il a été là
pendant le confinement il a eu des
problèmes il y avait le candidat qui ont
eu lieu il y avait le covid et puis en
Chine c'était compliqué il peut pas
sortir et donc pour les candidats il
faut les déplacer enfin il faut les
changer les dates quoi et
malheureusement la fille ne voulait pas
et donc du coup ce qui s'est passé c'est
que j'ai dû faire deux quarantaines de
deux semaines je crois il est resté un
mois à l'hôtel avant de faire le tournoi
et juste un mois à l'hôtel en voyant
personne loin de sa famille enfin il a
juste tilté complet quoi et il arrive au
tournoi il a fait n'importe quoi enfin
il était pas du tout pas du tout dans
les bonnes conditions pour jouer
c'est vraiment le joueur je pense qui a
été le plus impacté négativement par cet
épidémie c'est lui qui était dans une
sorte quasiment de 100 parties
d'invincibilité en classique
il montait vraiment pour être le
challenger de Carcassonne quoi c'est
tombé au pire moment pour lui ça vient
un grand coup d'arrêt dans sa carrière
et franchement il aurait pu il aurait pu
peut-être être
de venir champion du monde à ce
moment-là si ça fait plaisir qu'il est
finalement une nouvelle chance
dans le sens que il a pu se qualifier
par le hello enfin pour le vélo parce
que caryakim a été
du coup il a pu reprendre sa place et
dans les candidats et ben c'est 45 qui
jouent pas du coup il a été à chaque
fois repêché mais en finale on sait tous
que Ding franchement il a une période
difficile il est 40 méritant il est
monstreux et
poster du tout même si
même si il est pas là enfin je veux dire
même si c'est pas qualifié en vrai il a
clairement
donc voilà alors
Charles Kevin n'est pas là aujourd'hui
mais bon
on est là en tout cas qu'on va te faire
passer un meilleur moment
que tu alors tu reprends des forces
alors pour aller Raisa je pense qu'il a
du respect pour les raisins quand même
c'est un très très grand joueur après on
verra un petit peu comment allez
réserver bien sûr mais pour l'instant on
sait pas encore c'est pas la même
relation avec fil rouge un Star pour
faire je crois que c'est vraiment du
respect dans le sens où ils sont un peu
frites des fois dans des parties dans
des rapides ou quoi Taki il estime son
potentiel et son talent mais je pense
pas qu'il partirait peut-être en
vacances avec lui après pas qu'il soit
un mauvais termes non plus mais je veux
dire
quoi d'ailleurs je vais revenir un peu
sur cette qualité
qui a dit que peut-être qu'il cuisine
très bien et je te ferai remarquer Samy
que le pseudo cheescom de jingleeren
c'est
chef house
et je me dis bon ok peut-être que c'est
le cuisinier de la maison
ça me parle parce que c'est en fait dans
un tournoi pareil je me souviens je sais
plus où c'était c'était au tata
et des ateliers il y avait un atelier de
cuisine je sais pas ça te parle
que c'était 10 les reines d'après le
témoignage des autres joueurs qui sont
sortis le mieux là c'était Cauchemar en
cuisine et dit rien à priori il était
plutôt plutôt doué donc c'est peut-être
les
ok cool mais voilà donc du coup
peut-être que tu avais vu juste tes
larmante alors demain il y a la backup
demain à Paris ouais gros tournoi
organisé par Blitz stream et cheesecom
donc je sais pas trop trop d'infos sur
l'événement ça me tel que tu pourras
plus en parler moi demain je participe
pas vous savez j'habite loin j'habite au
canari pour bouger de chez moi il faut
vraiment
et bien c'est c'est un tournoi qui se
jouera certes sur internet mais sauf
qu'il faudra être présent à Paris tous
les ordinateurs sont là-bas donc ce sera
une première mondiale un tel événement
au niveau des échecs pareil très belle
règle je serai pas non plus mais pareil
je suivrai sans moi avec vous un peu le
stream et il y a une attente peut-être
qu'il est dans le chat
si c'est bien occupé de l'organisation
donc c'est à des questions il pourra
sûrement aussi répondre je sais pas à
quelle heure ça commence d'ailleurs mais
je crois que ça dure assez longtemps
parce qu'il y a deux séparés en deux
poules il y en a une poule
présidentielle avec Étienne Macron en
guestta et donc c'est vrai que Sebastien
Mazet la peau du capitaine et à l'issue
de tournoi il y aura je crois un petit
un petit tableau imitation directe entre
ceux qui tentent dans les premiers
à très bientôt merci c'est le 14 et 17h
du coup et donc j'imagine vers 20h
peut-être la phase finale
voilà voilà parfait Cyril merci
ce sera sur sur blit stream donc demain
toute la journée et bien sûr sur
cheesecom
il y aura du beau spectacle ouais ça va
être sympa ça va être sympa on m'a dit
un petit peu les joueurs qui étaient
présents et c'est pas mal hein
j'ai bien compris aussi il y aura du bon
niveau pas mal de Grand Maître très cool
ok donc la cavalue menace enfin d'aller
chatouiller le petit pion en H5 mais les
Noirs devraient s'en [ __ ] je pense et
commencer un petit peu à ramener les
pièces sur la colonne C peut-être
n'a pas un scénario très très proche de
la première partie du match studio j'ai
l'impression que même
et tout à l'heure dans cette position là
ça arrive le F6
pour tout manger d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être même position
et le fait qu'ils aient tous les deux
minutes
c'est drôle
donc
au final la dame noire qui vient un
petit peu s'activer la tour cible qui va
arriver sûrement en C2 et il y a du jeu
en fait les blancs de plus si on
commençait à suivre avec des dames G4 H5
H6 un truc comme ça
mais
je sais pas si la tête va vraiment
être effective
intéressante après jusqu'à masser
d'accord et que j'ai vu un message de
Resan dans le chat qui
disait encore ce cavalier en G6 tout
moche et c'est vrai que c'est
après ça va être parti de la préparation
de Nirvan dans cette ouverture mais
c'est vrai qu'il est quand même pas beau
ce qu'il y avait au G6 là
le 5 peut-être
et surtout le courage je prends là et
sur cavaler prend la plage je prends la
il y a tout emprise
pour le coup c'est un joueur qui perd
autant de temps en temps
recordman
c'est un super joueur mais c'est vrai
que en Bullet il est capable de perdre
autant quand il arrive plus de temps
alors que ça arrive
généralement il perd pas trop autant
quoi
plutôt très rapide il est rapide ouais
et même avec deux secondes on a vu
l'autre jour contre Gary contre guéri
avec 2 secondes à la pendule et tu
faisais des miracles il faut tout tempo
il voulait super coup et trouver des
tactiques avec plus de temps enfin bref
c'est vraiment
il y avait un peu commenté ce match il
me semble qu'il était venu plusieurs
fois sur un live et il disait de ça
arrive comme d'habitude on caricaturé un
peu il va faire un peu de la merde dans
les trois premières minutes tu vois du
match une fois qu'il aura plus que deux
secondes il a joué tous les meilleurs
couches à la fin de la partie et ça va
être hyper frustrant pour ses
adversaires
donc voilà comment comment car ça n'y
voit ça arrive donc c'est intéressant
quand même d'avoir
de Sarine dans cette partie qui mène
maintenant 2 1 du coup ça a mis les
paris sont toujours ouverts est-ce que
tu es prêt à parier sur digne alors
qu'il est mené d'un point
c'est vrai que là il m'a impressionné un
dans cette finale
Sarine franchement il est il a très très
bien joué ça allait très vite d'ailleurs
ça a basculé pour lui en 30 secondes
donc est-ce que je suis préparé
peut-être mais je ne sais toujours pas
quoi donc ça paraît complexe
Fatou vous avez des idées pour un
éventuel Paris avec Sami qui peut plus
entendre un petit peu le match n'hésitez
pas à nous
la 18 ans
tu vas avoir Naka contre aroniaque mvl
Sow et 400 koala dans l'ordre du coup
normalement c'est n'a qu'à Ronan lundi à
19h
mardi à 19h aussi et mercredi on aura
enfin nvl contre sceaux et encore une
fois à 19h donc trois soirs de suite des
belles affiches et c'est devrait
normalement être Kevin Bordy je sais pas
si il sera avec femme
Libye peut-être avec Étienne Macron pour
le match de mvl à voir pour les
commentaires
vous confirme ça dans les prochains
jours
et si jamais une nouvelle venue à guérir
par exemple il affronterait vainqueur du
match 47 Kawana en demi-finale alors que
le vainqueur de Smash donc affrontera
est probablement nakamurax ça fait
largement favori contre Harmonia
ça me fait penser j'ai rêvé cette nuit
que j'avais les cheveux teints en rose
mais vraiment
je crois que Paris va être accepté du
coup
il a pas du tout envie de faire un très
bon état
tout est lié ah oui
le cheveu c'est sacré
du coup pour revenir à la partie stuff
donc là
un beau mur de pion chez les Noirs au
centre quand même 4 pions liés ouais et
là je sais pas si on peut jouer ou pas
présente en dessin parce qu'en fait je
pense que noir ça va être T4 pour
essayer de
d'enfermer ce fou ces deux
et de gagner la case des quatre
éventuellement un jour peut-être tu vois
quand une fois que tu fais des quatre tu
as des idées souvent avec prise
bécran et P4 pour justement gagner la
casse D4 avec un petit cavalier un jour
et du coup des cas je pense c'est la
menace et du coup je sais pas si prise
en dessin du coup est possible pour
installer un Cavaillon 4 un truc comme
ça et essayer de limiter
[Musique]
c'est très compliqué ces Espagnols en
fait on a un milieu de jeu très dense
que vous voyez encore toutes les pièces
sur l'échiquier on est au 17e coup il y
a pas eu le moindre échanges et c'est
vraiment typique de ces variantes de la
rue Lopez où il y a beaucoup de
manœuvres et une tombe au centre et
c'est un petit peu du chantage qui va
céder le premier et en fonction bah ça
va donner des petits avantages à
l'adversaire et ça aussi c'était
Mathilde c'est d'aller mettre des
cavaliers en F5
moi je
le ferai si je perdais c'est super
battle bien sûr le problème
le problème c'est que je perds pas
je perds pas je perds pas
cavalier en F5 il en a un autre pour
revenir derrière si il prend
généralement on a bien faire fout le
sein qui après dame G4 etc genre deux
choses
mais voilà sur le long terme mais non
quand même plus d'espace au centre et
peut-être jouer un truc du style Kawaii
sexy prise en C3 et je B4 pour mettre du
cavalier en D4 c'est hyper hyper
thématique on voit ça très très souvent
qui doit revenir en jeu d'ailleurs le
cavalier A5 au bord qui est venu là
juste pour permettre la pousser ses 5
mais normalement il est pas avoué à y
rester longtemps
ça
ouais je pense qu'il joue depuis la
Chine
je pense effectivement à priori il a pas
fait de tournoi dernièrement là le
proche la prochaine grosse grosse
Kazakhstan ce sera meilleur commentaire
partout
entre autres et
du coup est-ce que dimirène les fera ces
championnats du monde c'est moins sûr je
crois pas que généralement
il est pas trop intéressant c'est rapide
c'est rien je me souviens pas
avoir vu son nom les dernières années
donc je crois qu'il les a pas fait
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être souvent le
seul joueur du Top Model qui manque un
appel voilà donc des fois on a eu des
Nakamura qui venaient pas des fois je
pense que maintenant que je pense qu'il
va jouer
quasiment sûr à mon avis on a du Naka du
carcène
firoga nvl bien sûr ça c'est du 26 au 30
décembre donc
c'est quand même un endroit très cool à
suivre très spectaculaire
une question de nique ta copine ouais
ceux qui viennent pas
non plus c'est vrai que c'est aussi
je sais pas c'est vrai que pourtant
c'est un joueur qui peut qui peut être
champion qui ferait partie des favoris
on a des pots qui vient généralement il
commence à il a déjà été champion du
monde de Blitz mais il commence deux
fois
sur la pompe descendante
dans les favoris
créer des petites des petites surprises
aussi
question technique pour toi
qu'est-ce que le pâtes c'est
[Musique]
quelquefois il peut avoir un mot depuis
on va avec lui qui sont bloqués donc ils
peuvent plus bouger mais tout simplement
c'est quand on par exemple
si je mets le roi noir ici dans le coin
là et qu'il y a plus de pièces de tout
les Noirs ont plus de pièces dans
colorant dans le coin et une dame
blanche par exemple que je mettrai ici
et plus haute pièce à part la dame
blanche et que c'est au noir de jouer le
noir pourra pas mettre son roi ici ici
ou ici parce que la dame fera échec tu
vois dans B6 contrôlera la case et j'ai
pas le droit de faire un groupe qui
mettrait en échec c'est interdit donc du
coup le patch ça arrive souvent sur les
débutants ça arrive
quasiment jamais
chez les chez les joueurs professionnels
comme Ding ou Sarine
ambulette Bullet ça peut arriver moi ça
m'arrive souvent d'ailleurs
en fait on a alors ça peut être
intéressant ça vous intéresse d'un
glossaire de terre mes chiens donc la
plupart ont été traduits en français
donc on explique justement des mots
comme comme le pat il y a des petites
vidéos c'est interactif donc je pense
voilà si tu cliques sur le lien tu auras
toutes les explications ce sera vraiment
a priori très clair
le mot zoubsangue il y a plein de choses
sur les tactiques aussi les fourchettes
peu parcourir un petit peu hésite pas et
peut-être ça pourra t'aider sur
l'apprentissage de certains mots et
comment ça marche
et ça je vais mettre aussi le lien de
zouksgang j'avais pas dit le WF Fatou
c'est ça là c'est la liste de différents
[Musique]
c'est pas trop si tu as gagné du coup si
tu as fait nul quand tu fais chaque
époque
alors donc là on va encore Dink quand
même il a 10 secondes contre 33
et un position compliqué dans le
cavalier F5 qui est devenu par un clouer
maintenant le fou qui vient en mettre
que des positions
parce qu'il y aura Tourcoing encore
mieux donc faut pas encore vu mais la
tour elle a pas de casse non plus
enfermé et c'est un qui prend son temps
aussi dans ce match et il a avoir avant
beaucoup de temps d'avance et ben il
et on sait que c'est un danger pour lui
justement normalement faudrait qu'il
évite de se retrouver dans une situation
et peu de temps la pendule c'est là où
il est peut-être le plus friable par
rapport à
ça
avec peu de temps
ils ont plus de temps la pendule j'ai
peur de trouver cette
il y a la dame la Dame Blanche un peu
enfermée mais la tournoi attention
ça grignote des pions ça j'aime bien ce
coup
j'ai un
attention ils ont plus de temps la
pendule plus que deux secondes chacun
incroyable il a oublié de jouer il a
oublié de jouer voilà
[Musique]
en dessin
ah oui pardon 4
en fait il a été choqué je pense par la
gamme
pour dire c'est pas possible je gagne
vraiment la dame et il est tombé il
aurait pu creuser le score à 3-1 et au
final et au final de 2 dans ce match va
avoir très cher ça à la fin du match
quand on sait comme c'est serré que ça
joue souvent un point de départage ça
fait deux d'écart par rapport à une
victoire de Sarine ça peut compter
lourdement et salut à toi attends junior
salut patata
prise en passant surtout la présentation
fait clairement partie
du jeu quel que soit le niveau je pense
pas qu'elle soit plus fréquente à bas
niveau qu'à haut niveau c'est plus
le hasard entre guillemets d'une
configuration où c'est possible c'est
juste que les joueurs par contre quand
il y a une présentation ils savent que
l'autre peut faire la prise en passant
et considère que c'est pas grave
ils vont pas être surpris par la prise
en passant mais ouais il y a des valeurs
de même théoriques où il y a des prisons
pas de sens
[Musique]
qui qui est juste
chez débutant ça peut souvent surprendre
parce qu'on n'est jamais sûr des fois et
même pas que chez les débutants moi j'ai
un souvenir quand je travaillais avec
Club de Cannes echec j'avais une élève
qui avait à peu près 1700 hello qui un
jour m'avait dit Stéphane j'ai un
problème tu rigoles pas tu rigoles pas
mais j'ai toujours un doute pour la
présentation comment ça marche
1700 moi j'ai fait non sérieux
des fois je l'ai reparti et j'ose pas le
faire parce que j'ai peur des couilles
légaux et comme je suis pas sûr de la
règle
parce qu'après
ça marche pas tu es obligé quand même de
jouer ton pion et à 1700 hello facial
quand tu es débutant ok bon mais à 1700
euros ça fait un peu peur et du coup
voilà
[Musique]
j'ai pas de
connait la présentation si c'était ta
question pense qu'il la connaît ouais
au niveau de la partie qu'est-ce que ça
donne
les rennes qui a de nouveau les pièces
blanches
il avait commencé le match par
e46 et maintenant il passe à D4 et on a
encore une position
qui est pas du tout ennuyeuse on voit
qu'il y a déjà des des colonnes ouvertes
un roi au centre
exactement le bordel alors moi je
pensais à une idée comme T5 mais
l'idée en fait c'est quand tu manges je
pensais faire fou et chèque et sur comme
fou d'essai j'ai du cavaler des six le
temps qu'il peut vite arriver etc mais
en fait je pense qu'après un truc comme
ça avec échec fou des 7 le roi est fuite
et au final la colonne c'est va être
utilisée pour parler noir pour attaquer
et même peut-être même des cinq cavaler
prendre des cinq cavaler pour ton point
pour éliminer la pièce qui défend la
dame qui couvre le clouage et après sur
échecs
C8 avec clouage je
ma valeur forcément très bon pour les
Noirs mais ça avait l'air intéressant en
tout cas à calculer fais attention quand
on fait grand rock souvent on va jouer
le petit courroie B1 automatique après
profilactique ou juste sans lever des
problèmes pour un coup utile même si là
faudra faire attention à la diagonale
blanche aussi parce qu'un fond noir pour
arriver au F5 à terme si c'est pas
forcément tout de suite bon mais
par rapport à ce que tu sais je voulais
dire que roi et feat serait pas été en
catastrophique pour les Noirs dans ce
genre de position des fois le roi il
peut trouver un abri de fortune ici en
fait sur case noire vous voyez que dans
cette position les Blancs ne possèdent
pas de foucasse noir du coup si je vais
me rendre sur case noire mais un truc
comme ça en bougeant un peu ça peut ça
peut tenir pour les noirs
[Musique]
généralement quand le roi a dit OK et
que le jeu est ouvert c'est pas si grave
mec l'absence chez les Blancs
c'est justifiable on va dire
du coup c'est clair pour qu'on en ferait
power voilà si tu touches une pièce mais
qui n'est pas la bougie la bouche pas
quoi
non non en fait
tu peux avoir une qualité de temps si tu
joues le coup tu es plus à la pendule
c'est considéré comme un coup illégal en
fait un coup illégal c'est quand tu as
appuyé sur la formule c'est à dire que
même si je touche une pièce offre pas la
joie bah t'as pas jouécu en fait et vu
que t'as pas pu sur la pendule t'as pas
je vais le coup en entier si tu veux et
du coup il y a pas de pénalité de temps
enfin après ils vont changer depuis
simplement longtemps que j'ai pas fait
de stage d'arbitre donc c'est pas
arbitré non plus mais à l'époque c'était
comme ça je pense que ça allait toujours
d'ailleurs
la position qui s'ouvre quand même alors
que le roi de miracle est toujours au
centre c'est quand même très dangereux
et cette fois-ci regarde la pendule donc
ça c'est peut-être de bonne augure pour
dire Rennes il y a plus deux minutes
d'avance
et ça devrait éviter peut-être de même
si la partie d'avant il est beaucoup de
chance de réussite à la fin et
d'ailleurs la partie la partie d'avant
qui fait beaucoup de mal à Sarine qui
qui peut dans ce match peut-être lui les
valeurs beaucoup parce qu'il aurait pu
être à 3-1 et là il est à deux deux et
là ils sont encore mal maintenant cette
partie si personne là c'est un peu
tourner ça peut tourner la musique
tous les risques pour ouvrir les lignes
de partout alors faut prendre
ce qui cherche à faire en fait c'est
juste faire tout un avec découverte sur
le roi et après ouvrir le jeu et
profiter du fait qu'il est mieux
développé et que le roi blanc est encore
en 8
n'est pas une petite réaction de grichu
par rapport à quoi par rapport au fait
qu'il est mal au temps
je sais pas si on lentille se met mal
autant comme ça sauf je pense pas non
après là c'est une partie mais
généralement ça rime avec rapide mais il
est en tout cas très très bon et comme
great show qui est effectivement et que
2 secondes à la pendule mais c'est un
peu une machine comme Naka aussi très
peu de temps oui raisonne vous prendrez
4 Roy F8 surtout un mais bon taken
d'accord que c'est chaud maintenant et
la brochette de fou sur la colonne g euh
à la place des Noirs j'aurais un peu
peur quand même
mais bon bien sûr après dingly Rennes je
pense qu'il a pas non plus calculé ça
vraiment un profondément juste il sent
que c'est le bon coup il veut ouvrir les
lignes qui tout à fait logique et elles
sont en blitz on peut pas te calculer
avec quoi on reprend justement ce four
il dit quoi ton instinct ou le cheval
pour se faire tourner
je préférerais parce que j'ai une
carence à 5 qui est intéressante et
j'ai l'impression que je perds un temps
proposé juste pour te pour te pour
tilter il y avait
aucune raison
en fait ça récupère juste la pièce le
calme la virtuellement les noirs avec
une pièce de plus mais
avant mais après juste on a récupéré le
matériel et ça arrive il a pas peur il
était de manger spion des quatre il a
sûrement mettre comme tu avais dit un
petit peu avant son range G7 sera
peut-être en abri finalement pas si mal
après dans la position objectivement
elle est quand même pas très bien et je
pense que comme et ben il est pas très
bien et ben il se dit qu'il faut qu'il
prenne des risques
parce que sinon
je pense une magnifique Manor son cahier
qui était en C3 elle a vu le spot en F5
et en trois temps il va arriver en F5
est-ce qu'elle va aller en F5 qui sera
monstrueux tout simplement autour du roi
noir il contrôlera beaucoup de casse-clé
il fera très mal je préfère acheter
d'ailleurs plutôt que 5 parce que je
prends la case du four aussi en F6 et ça
me permettrait de pouvoir manger ce fout
de manière quasi forcée pas trop
d'accord parce qu'il y a le pion affiche
[Musique]
il voulait bien
dans tous les cas les Blancs ont été
très très grosse compensations pour
l'option il y a faux F3 le cavalier qui
vient de partout les colonnes qui va
venir ici le pion vient je m'en fous un
peu en finale
je pense que j'ai mieux à faire que ça
là puis farine qui a plus de 6 secondes
à la pendule c'est délicat
[Musique]
en fait il vaut 1000 fois plus que ta
vieille tour en H8 donc du coup il y a
pas moyen que je mange la qualité
puisque la qualité même là
mon fou il est en prise j'empêche le
chèque ici
tu vois toutes les trois et puis on
rentre ce qui se passe donc
l'idée il y a un petit piège qui est une
fourchette il en a raté une toute à
l'heure belle fourchette donc il veut
peut-être essayer de
de compenser c'est que cette fois digne
il devrait pas tomber dans le panneau
non
s'il avait pris le fouiller la
fourchette encore une fois oh là là mais
du coup il a craqué un peu là il y a des
risques un peu de partout
ça a l'air
tu aimes bien fousser de
comment on continue ici dame G4 ok je
pense que il a réussi à marcher et
parfois à chaque fois
[Musique]
ça va
craquage de Digne incroyable
c'est la pause
qui qui a déstabilisé se [ __ ] en B2 de
Sarine
c'est la pause peut-être revenir un peu
en arrière du coup
je pense pas que ce soit la connexion à
l'exercice salut salut Pauline
[Musique]
sur 3 G7 ouais c'est pas simple quand
même c'est pas si simple faut prendre
les deux
ça te fait un peu de choc ouais mais
c'est vrai que tu enlever la tour de la
première rangée c'est compliqué hein
parce que là il y a quand même un il y a
encore une fois la fourchette qui arrive
remontrer il a raté le gain de dames
très facile hyper facile digérer un peu
plus tard
et là c'est perdu c'est perdu parce
qu'il y a foi cet échec et il a raté
c'est incroyable
qui est dingue qui est dingue ouh là là
excusez-moi aujourd'hui je suis vraiment
du coup F5 c'est dingue
[Musique]
c'est ouf qu'il est pas qu'il est pas
trouvé quand même fou F5
et choquant
ça gagne apparemment
qui est ultra difficile à voir
initiative tu as envie de faire des
échecs de garder la main et à fouet
fuite là
[Musique]
pour défendre la tour j'ai pas de case
là il y a le fou là il y a le cavalier
là il y a le fou la seule moyenne de
défendre la tour c'est de faire ça quoi
ah mais ça c'est joli ça en Bullet avec
3 jours de la pendule ça trouvable
c'est introuvable
introuvable salut hélène
est arrivé au bon moment effectivement
avec une fin de partie au scénario à
Saint vraisemblable mais depuis le début
du match on a que des parties hyper
excitantes très très tactique vous
voulez des joueurs réfléchissent
beaucoup dans l'ouverture qui se mettent
mal au temps
et du coup c'est très indécinant pour
l'instant ce match la partie juste avant
donc on a Sarine qui a perdu autant
alors qu'il pouvait faire une fourchette
royale gagner la dame en un coup à ce
moment là
et cette fois-ci
c'est lui qui retourne complètement une
situation
perdu autant en 5 parties il y en a eu
deux qui sont joués au temps
et on est que segment de 5 plus donc ça
promet pour la suite
pas trop fatigué
non ça va
c'est une machine de guerre tout fait
bien entraîné il fait des randos le
matin et des streams l'après midi alors
la rando d'hier au final on l'a pas
faite
on sait pas levé mais bon j'enchaîné les
deux les deux matchs derrière la rando
je pense qu'elle m'aurait juste
complètement tué
mais du coup du coup non j'ai pas
parfait de rando mais non c'est
fatiguant quand même en plus j'ai pas
mal de cours que je dois je dois
rattraper du coup là j'ai eu pas mal de
cours en fait tous les jours avant les
lives et manger des cours
ce qui fait que ça me fait quand même
des grosses journées mais
de suite là c'est beaucoup hier c'était
hier c'était beaucoup hier c'était
beaucoup
mais bon ça va ça va au final bah ça
passe vite parce que l'événement est
vraiment cool
et
ça passe vite
ça se passe vite Samy je profite la pub
cette seconde là pour aller
prendre de l'eau je reviens dans une
mini pause je sais pas pendant combien
de temps les gens reviennent ils vont
arriver mais surtout on fait une pause
d'une minute mais on va dans une minute
si vous voulez tout de suite à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes revenus ça a été bref
mais
intense voilà je vais prendre ma
bouteille de ma bouteille d'eau
[Musique]
qui est ici
et
donc voilà ça va reprendre
3 2 pour l'instant pour pour ça
on a l'arbitre qui qui appelle qui
appelle Ding
UE
extrêmement serrées ça c'est ce qu'on
souhaite on a vu que Sarine l'a déjà
gagné son huitième de finale après
prolongation à l'arraché d'un point donc
peut-être qu'on va encore avoir un
scénario à rallonge aujourd'hui c'est
pas impossible
[Musique]
de défendre toute façon des positions
comme ça même si ça sent mon autre il
joue pas les meilleurs coups c'est
pareil on défend souvent on va se
tromper c'est trop dur
alors que se passe-t-il pourquoi les
joueurs ne surrai match pas
ouais
il y a un lien entre Samira et Robinson
et mon pseudo voilà une façon de dire
qu'il y a un lien peut-être
[Musique]
mais c'est reparti du coup stuff ouais
tu vas pas la partie là
c'est pas que je parlais aussi bien
anglais à thé vert je suis surpris
hop
Robin côté ouais c'est ça ouais
plein de pions en prise au centre
la position qui à ce moment-là pourrait
un petit peu exploser alors les blancs
prise et une réaction au centre
généralement parce qu'en le 5 on peut
tomber plus tard avec un pion isolé
effectivement donc souvent on va manger
je veux cinq ou manger et faire ces cinq
c'est souvent ce plutôt de réponse comme
ça qu'on va attendre
alors que les blancs ils vont peut-être
le plus tôt 4
et je pense que là ça rime va devoir
peut-être balancer le cadre
c'est le moment pris de la calculer
après les différents échanges ça dame
aurait permis dans le cadre et se
retrouve en face du foie adverse mais
pour l'instant ce fond de gaz blanche
des Noirs il n'est pas défendu donc il y
aurait pas de découverte
possiblement il va y avoir une rupture
au centre donc c'est un bon moment pour
essayer de prendre un peu son temps elle
a pris des 5 ok voilà du coup je pense
intéressant parce que sur pion prend je
vais cavalier bassin qui peut être
intéressant
je peux t'en mettre un peu peut-être
et du coup c'est un moyen d'avoir
peut-être un déjà avantage de structure
donc Ding qui joue du coup c'est prendre
à 5 qui veut pas avoir ce défaut
structure
parce que tous les quatre toujours un
peu tendu genre de coup le fou il passe
table en fait
à 6 direct il veut pas de se cavaler en
B5 ce qui est très bien joué d'ailleurs
à 6
elle a gardé la symétrie du coup au
niveau de la structure dim on reprenant
du pion C je pense que là il a il a
réussi à obtenir à l'égalité Sami
pour l'égalité s'il avait pris de l'eau
de pion c'était peut-être plus à
trois résultats en tout cas plus
bordélique
là ça paraît très égal très solide de
côté très symétrique en termes
d'organisation
mais on écoute au début tout peut se
passer on va dire c'est la première
partie pour l'instant je dis bien pour
l'instant un peu calme
il a pas dû aimer les plans avec E4 je
pense ça rien
un moment donné je pense à 3 pour me
placer ici et du coup ouvrir mon fou il
me permet de jouer un jour cavalier au 5
voilà
je pense enfin histoire diagonale
peut-être cette partie pour être la
première nulle de ce match bon après
encore beaucoup de choses à faire quand
même il y aura beaucoup de place c'est
la première fois en tout cas qu'on a une
position tranquille
toutes les colonnes ouvertes sur les
rois après 15 coups
[Musique]
les deux coups
candidats
sur la colonne C et
alors d'être le coup forcément ok
on sait par qui après faut aussi voir
quand même que les Blancs certes ils ont
la colonne c'est pour l'instant de toute
façon il menacent jamais de rentrer
parce qu'on contrôle toutes les cases
d'entrée donc c'est pas si grave pas si
dérangeant
ouais alors comme j'ai mis une caverne 4
peut-être que je peux un jour
terminé avec F5 et même peut-être que G5
derrière et commencer la taxe sur le roi
blanc avec G4 TH4
c'est intéressant comme comme plan
je suis d'accord avec toi thématique ou
bien du coup qui
qui anticipe pour ces 8
donc là je vois bien
F5 ou pour avoir du ke5 et dire avec les
Blancs moi toi tu as joué F5 moi je peux
jouer F3 si je veux pour chasser ton
cavalier
c'est pas si c'est décisif mais
peut-être que pour ça qu'on réfléchit
avant de jouer F5
plus j'ai ramené l'autre qui allait au
FC jouer torse vite maintenant
[Musique]
ok
ok H5
H5 intéressant j'ai pas pensé
moi il veut il veut sûrement faire la
même
il veut sûrement faire la même
intéressant H5 et c'est pas du tout un
coup que j'avais dans la coupe candidat
et pourtant
privé le cavalier de la case G3
intéressant l'idée de dingue qui est
quatre H3 et je veux pas torser vite il
pourrait essayer de liquider un peu
toutes les pièces dans la colonne C par
exemple mais pour l'instant il veut
garder les pièces et essayer de
d'attaquer
la raison
et je pense c'est quand même lui qui
commence à obtenir un peu des des choses
dans cette position cavalière 3
peut-être imaginé un dommage 6 avec
l'idée de faire j'ai 5 et commencer
réellement l'attaque avec G5 G4 et si je
regarde
l'initiative ici quand même la Dame
Blanche est pas très bien placée donc il
est revenu en recettes donc il est il
est il doit être content digne du coup
d'avoir
[Musique]
d'avoir provoqué le coût F4
il a un beau cavalier en E4 qui peut
plus être chassé par un pion donc est-ce
que F6 peut être une idée ici pour pour
le noir pour virer ce cavalier et
replacer la dame peut-être via des 6 G6
et sur mettre en face du Renoir et puis
essayer d'attaquer quoi
malheur pas mal même un jour peut-être
même
pousser le 5 bannière ou d'une autre
pour vraiment ouvrir les deux fous ça
c'est un peu moins sûr
mais en tout cas ça a rien qui vient
d'avoir du mal à trouver ici
les réponses beaucoup et finit par
échanger en local OK
je peux toujours défendre et plus tard
jouer à 4 par exemple cavalier F6 plus
h4k
[Musique]
14 secondes à la pendule contre deux
minutes cinq qui est très très lent ça
c'est bizarre parce que ça rink contre
d'autres joueurs j'aime mal au temps et
là aujourd'hui entre Jean il est hyper
mal aux dents on espère je sais pas
c'est les positions aussi qui sont
complexes
[Musique]
du coup est-ce que on va pas trouver des
compensations ailleurs
donc je dois manger le cavalier bien vu
il réfléchit pas sur fulpron cavalier il
réfléchissait sur la suite parce que il
sait que son adversaire est mal au temps
et du coup il veut enchaîner peut-être à
tempo
donc il a coupé 4 intermédiaire et
maintenant on va défendre donc un B7 il
y a quand même ton C2 qui arrive
et donc
la dame de la tour qui bloque la dame
sur la défense du pion en 4 donc c'est
très bien je la part de Digne tout un
très précis tu vois les quatre très
précis
le blanc pond certes le contrôle absolu
de la colonne C mais
alors autre pièce sont plutôt passives
en défense donc
petite préférence pour les Noirs ici
même si en pratique ça a l'air pas si
clair encore comment on continue là avec
avec les Noirs en fait le cavalier est
fin est une mauvaise pièce vous pouvez
aussi une mauvaise pièce deux pièces qui
ne changeront jamais et pendant ce temps
les noirs doivent essayer de faire des
choses donc moi je pense changer les
tours et dames c'est pas mal du tout
l'échange les pièces longues étaient à
l'avantage plutôt de sa riz mais les
pièces sont davantage et du coup il veut
liquider les pièces lourdes donc c'est
ça et
salut à toi non non
sache que équipe en Espagne et ben c'est
masculin donc tu aurais dû garder ton
dossier j'ai cinq la rupture qui arrive
ici et vous l'avez dit les pièces
mineures des blancs qui sont très très
passives
franchement tu vois une partie qui avait
l'air complètement égal à qui en fait
damachu qui va arriver on sent la frise
damlin
un truc pour attendre au final qui va
faire le tour avec sa dame rentrer par
par ici
exploite toute la géométrie de
l'échiquier là c'est encore parti pour
être une masterclass alors la partie
d'avant c'était une masterclass et puis
c'est complètement écrou à la fin dit
mais rien ne va voir si là il arrive à
conclure elle est jusqu'au bout mais là
il a quand même deux secondes
F4 certainement les plantes sont obligés
de reprendre avec eux pour éviter faut
H4 maths
quand même et le pion des Quatre
[Musique]
Temps voilà il est tombé
de la tête et des épaules
elle a pendule aussi il avait énormément
de marge il a pas réussi à
la chose vraiment il faut qu'il se force
à se dire bah quand j'ai 10 secondes en
fait j'ai perdu autant il va pas passer
sous les 10 secondes parce que
à chaque fois ça se passe mal à la fin
quoi
qui est mute
aussi
Jinger parce que bon il a été là en fin
de partie mais
[Musique]
il est un petit peu
de 3 secondes c'est ça tient pas
il arrive à trois coups
depuis le début donc
là ça commence à faire parce que c'est
la cadence où les sons secs le plus
favori
il commence à prendre du retard même si
depuis le début tu débutes on avait pas
mal de surprises de joueurs présumé l'an
le moins bon ambulette qui ont dominé
les bullets justement mais ça c'est une
légende parce qu'en fait
à chaque fois depuis le début c'est
comme ça tu vois non il est pas très bon
angulaire
oui mais par exemple moi
déchire ça arrive en Villette c'était
une grosse surprise ouais ça c'est vrai
et il y avait aussi le
demande ce qui se passe
c'est bon
pourquoi du coup parce que
dit que des problèmes de connexion et
et du coup il a voulu lui rendre lui
rendre l'appareil enfin l'appareil on a
vraiment mais lui rendre un point c'est
c'est beau en vrai c'est beau
le bel état d'esprit ouais
il a quand même donné quand il avait les
Noirs mais quand même
mais
je sais pas si on a d'autres d'ailleurs
qui aurait peut-être 10000 les mêmes
aurait pu le faire mais
un beau jour il peut le faire
oui car c'est sur un beau jour et ça
dépend compte qui en fait encore une
fois parce que il
aurait dit va te faire
par contre contreding en fait si vous
voulez digne il est il est il est
vachement respecté dans le milieu en
fait et il est hyper gentil et tout ça
je pense franchement que je pense
franchement que
oui c'est sûr ça c'est
du joueur a clairement joué dans sa
faveur
en tout cas très beau geste on peut
quand même de farine qui qui rendent
point c'est vraiment cool et c'est pas
un petit cavaluer
un peu de partout parce que si on mange
bah je prends le fou et après tout
[Musique]
à la maison et qui avait les béca je
bouge mon fou et là je bouge
très justement remarquer Nathan qui est
encore plus fort
que chèques merci Nathan je pense que
nos commentaires sont quand même assez
comment dire
une partie où il y a une fourchette mais
bon j'imagine qu'il estime que c'était
pas de la connexion c'est juste qu'il a
perdu autant parce que non mais ça fait
quand même deux fois que Ding est hyper
autant quand même et du coup bon
tu vois
la partie où il a quand même une tour de
plus et qui fait à ça qui peut jouer à
B5 c'est de la partie un peu folle bon
il perd autant je pense pas que ça
revient la connexion même si ça peut
jouer aussi un coup tu sais quand tu
regardes tout le temps et que à la fin
tu as pas forcément
quoi mais bon cette partie là il
considérait quand même qu'il était qu'il
était perdant qui s'était fait
complètement mais là c'est vrai que la
partie d'avant il savait quand même
explosé il a pas vécu il s'est il a subi
une vraie masterclass et il a gagné par
à cause de la connexion de l'adversaire
donc il a rendu le point ce qui est
franchement ultra fair-play et quelque
chose qu'on voit d'ailleurs très très
peu de nos jours donc en vrai
qui est une constante de ces de ces
matchs
pour attaquer créer du jeu sur la loi
c'est ça
quand j'étais parti en Inde de faire ce
stage avec l'équipe de canechec il y a
quelques années et ben il y avait un
mèche que vous avez appris le fameux le
radar le radar en fait c'est Quentin de
pollution tu sais pas quoi améliorer
c'est pas quel coût comment faire et en
fait pour rechercher si tu veux les
candidats
automatiquement par la colonne A la
colonne B et la colonne etc pour
chercher un petit peu les candidats et
il a eu une partie où en fait il savait
pas quoi faire et dans la partie c'est
la partie de lui on te ramènes il avait
joué en fait H4 dans une position qui
ressemble un peu à ça un peu différente
et il a besoin H4 parce qu'il voyait pas
d'autres coups mieux que ça pour
améliorer et en fait H4 pour faire G4 si
tu veux c'est les deux prochains coups
arcade G4 tu vois la production tu dis
mais attends mais enfin ça a l'air
stupide mais en fait c'était hyper fort
c'était cool l'ordinateur et c'est qu'il
avait joué aussi et il avait trouvé ça
par rapport à une technique qui
s'appelle le radar qui était très
intéressant
donc bon là c'est pas là c'est pas la
même chose il y a un pion en E5 quand
même ce qui rend vulnérable les cases
noires en dccf6 et du coup c'est tout
est logique il veut le mettre le pion en
H6 pour provoquer G6 et éventuellement
inviter une pièce en F6 donc à un plan
qu'on peut imaginer c'est à chaque H6
provoqué G6 jouer foi H4 pour échanger
le [ __ ] case noir et un moment donné
essayer de ramener un f-6 tu vois genre
de choses quoi
les pièces blanches un pointe plutôt sur
le bras noir donc on a besoin de créer
des choses autour de soi créer des
brèches et des pièces tout seuls vont
pas suffire on va avoir besoin de l'aide
d'un pion on a pu on le sein comme tu as
dit qu'un un bel épine un petit peu dans
la position mais le personnage est là
pour faire des trous supplémentaires
salut c'est Baptiste
est-ce que tu connais le bouquin de oui
là
sont hyper bien franchement confiance
avec je n'ai pas lu j'ai feuilleté mais
je sais pas lu le Conseil le bouquin est
hyper bien je n'ai pas lu non mais j'ai
eu beaucoup de route beaucoup de très
bons retours
entre autres et pas que je sais que j'ai
eu de très bons retours en fait de ce
bouquin mais moi je l'ai feuilleté mais
je l'ai fallu en entier vous savez que
moi je suis je suis un mauvais élève
mercredi à 19h Sébastien contre sceaux
pour les autres quarts de finale
voilà c'est facile à souvenirs tous les
soirs à 19h la semaine prochaine
non plus à mon avis bah écoute le
premier je l'ai
parce que
je m'en sers pour les cours
et non non c'est c'est un très bon
bouquin d'ailleurs je recommande par
contre le numéro 2 je le recommande pas
parce que je l'ai pas lu et je l'ai pas
vu
en fait Sami qui voulait me l'envoyer
mais malheureusement j'habite très très
loin et du coup on a pas encore fait ça
c'est compliqué au niveau de la douane
ouais en fait j'ai
peut-être mes livres j'ai eu ça coûte
très très cher bon allez au Japon
non en fait les Canaries souvent quand
on voit des des
colis là-bas et ben un reste bloqué à
Madrid et du coup il faut payer une
douane donc j'avais quelqu'un qui
m'avait envoyé un une fois un colis il a
été renvoyé chez lui il a lui le
renvoyait par un autre truc donc ça fait
deux envois au final pour que je le
reçois c'est un peu compliqué quand en
gros
peut-être à avoine Samy
je sais pas si je reviendrai en France
avant si je passe je passe je passe deux
semaines en France en janvier mais mais
à Nice je pense pas que qu'on se
croisera
mais en vrai c'est un truc qui pourrait
me chauffer le Japon pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas
je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
j'en sais rien mais c'est vrai que que
c'est compliqué d'ailleurs quand tu veux
acheter les trucs genre Amazon ou quoi
et ben il y a beaucoup beaucoup de de
transporteur qui refusent de te livrer
qu'un arrêt quoi c'est chiant à chaque
fois que tu veux un truc tu dis c'est
bon ajoute au panier et dès que tu veux
te faire livrer ah non désolé on livre
pas qu'on arrive
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
peut-être un jour
je vais revenir un peu sur le continent
il y a plein de problèmes c'est un peu
loin en fait j'ai un peu exilé au final
et Sarine qui est encore très très mal
au temps c'est comme incroyable toutes
les parties il est il est à 4 secondes
et mal au temps et mal sur les chic et
c'est quand même fait manger tous ces
pions après il tente le tout pour le
tout sur le roi mais
il y a beaucoup de tours de moins
alors complètement gagnant
encore une fois et cette fois peut
espérer ne perde pas autant et que 2
minutes contre 3 secondes mais il avait
tout à l'heure il avait une minute le
calque contre trois secondes et il a
fini par perdre autant la partie où
Sarine a abandonné tu sais enfin le seul
pour laquelle il abandonné
attention en fait il faut qu'il arrive à
garder le rythme une fois qu'il est
[Musique]
serait marrant qu'il abandonne et que
Sarine dit non mais en fait c'est bon
j'étais foutu donc il abandonne derrière
on préfère un match comme ça en fait ils
abandonnent à tour de rôle
et le plus de fois gagne le match ouais
et donc là du coup H6 avoir utilisé par
par Sarine dans le match contre guérir
et jouer sans arrêt ça
sans arrêt ça donc c'est une ligne qui
qui est intéressante qui est très solide
pour les Noirs en tout cas pour le Blitz
c'était assez efficace d'arriver à jouer
très vite sans trop se poser de
questions
et quatre partout mais du coup c'est
légalisation de Digne qui est élevé 4-2
et qui revient en hauteur donc c'est
quand même un moment important du match
et ça lui a la Dino bienvenue à toi
salut à toi
puisque tu as raté un match très serré
avec
des
alertes un petit peu de connexion de
défaites autant de joueurs faire play
qui abandonnent pour compenser à des
fêtes
un truc que tu verras pas souvent dans
les speechess je pense
en tout cas après si moi j'aime bien
c'est ce côté un peu tu vois il y avait
dans 15 scène on en a parlé je pense
dans ces beaux jours il pouvait faire là
c'est ça qui a abandonné pour rendre un
point que dit minérale avait perdu à
cause de sa connexion alors qu'il allait
probablement gagner
et d'ailleurs j'avais vu il y avait une
partie où il me semble que carrassen
avait abandonné au 1er ou deuxième coup
contre dingly Rennes aussi
en fait c'est très malin d'être
extrêmement
modeste respectueux comme ça tous les
joueurs sont hyper fairplay avec toi
ensuite
[Musique]
ça mais
voilà je pense que Nathan n'a pas eu les
consignes de ni garage je suis là
c'était pas les mêmes non
parler de ce
à faire qui est en cours
c'est ça Néandertal effectivement
c'est pour ça que je le dis
effectivement en ce moment il y a pas
mal d'infos là-dessus la NACA aussi qui
a
réagit pour essayer de faire en sorte
que la plante de Neman soit déboutée
donc
mercredi à 19
et on a ça rime du coup qui bloque sur
le F4 de 10 mm dans cette position
que toutes les parties il est mal au
temps c'est pas ce que nous
c'est pas du tout ce qui nous
montrait avant le match contre
[Musique]
moi j'aime bien un truc avec cavalier
prend donc tout prend et F5 F6 mais je
sais pas si ça si c'est bon ou pas
tout bêtement
complexe effectivement Cyril
pour avoir justement un peu traduit les
articles aussi là dessus c'est un sacré
bordel
sans que ni tête
et il a pas repris en ces 5 ça arrive
alors
c'est un peu surprenant j'ai pas
forcément compris exactement
5 il y a une pièce
mais du coup qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
avec le nom ici
si on essaie d'enlever cette dame
salut Kevin
[Musique]
tu aurais parié sur ton poulain
je veux bien connaître la vie de Kevin
comme ça je fais l'inverse et là je suis
prêt à parier ça et son compagnon de
club c'est ça
moi j'aurais été chaude parier Ding
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs Kevin si tu avais
stream avec moi je crois que tu aurais
été
vert parce que
Ding a perdu une partie à cause de la
connexion enfin à cause d'un lag de
connexion alors tu as une position
complètement gagnante et du coup et du
coup ce qu'a fait ce qu'a fait sa ring
c'est la partie d'après il a abandonné
au bout de trois coups pour lui rendre
le point qu'il avait qu'il avait perdu à
cause de la déconnexion
et du coup Kevin je pense que
je pense que Kévin n'aurait pas apprécié
le fair-play non de son plein
et toi tu l'aurais pas accepté
en tout cas sympa
la part de Sarine qui a rendu le point
rendu le point
perdu la connexion à adding ça te va
vraiment que les joueurs se respectent
énormément l'arbitre ça rime du
fair-play dans une grosse réflexion
qu'au 16e couple ça va être le 17e et il
a déjà dépensé 4 minutes donc vraiment
falloir que deux jours il osent le
rythme pour la portion de 3 plus une
Karim sera peut-être d'ailleurs la
dernière partie ou l'avant dernière
aussi j'aurais gueulé à ta place
je suis fair-play aussi mais je rigolais
aussi
quand même on rigole plus
il se passe des choses en rapport avec
ton pull ah oui alors
on en a parlé ton pull tout à l'heure
pas tout le monde
récupérer donc
plus ou pas finalement de plus pour les
blancs à terme
alors je suis un peu stressé là je sais
pas si tu entends Samy parce que si je
dois le bruit mais dans mes oreillettes
j'entends comme une
horloge chaque seconde dans ta tête
alors non ça doit être chez Ding ou chez
Sarine mais je pense cette ligne la loge
de l'autre côté de la caméra un petit
peu facile s'il te plaît je te promets
que j'entends chaque seconde j'entends
le truc il va me rendre fou
combien de secondes en 4 heures ça a mis
on va demander à Nathan que dans le chat
qui ont un coucou chez eux ça c'est vrai
que c'est une invention de ouf
je te promets il y a vraiment un bruit
il y a vraiment un bruit
14400 merci donc là j'ai passé 1h37
combien ça fait qu'il en reste
absolument rien je pense que j'entends
dans mes en fait moi je suis connecté au
zoom si tu veux avec eux et joueurs ils
ont
ils ont ils ont le micro et tout et du
coup quand ils parlent j'entends petite
pastèque avec les deux fous qui sont
attaqués à tourtereaux prise à 5 et
internet je pense oui
bien vu
ça avec un pion de plus côté blanc
est-ce que ça va suffire pour gagner
c'est pas sûr
elle est quand même réduit
je pense qu'on va peut-être assister à
la première nuit du match cette fois
c'est tout
c'est vrai que ce pion E3
va pas suffire tout à 5 pour les blancs
pour défendre le pion à 4 attaquer le
plus loin six
tomber je sais pas si vous avez vu les
gens icaruno Go pour ceux qui arrivent
ce manga que je kiffe de ouf et du coup
j'entendais voir si je pouvais avoir un
Fisher dans ma tête bon par contre juste
pour les échecs
après je te laisse partir
même peut-être à passer un peu plus que
ami avec fichier dans ta tête tout
il a pas envie de finir sur le bûcher à
mon avis
de ce match on sait jamais que c'était
des joueurs il peut y avoir un problème
de connexion une défaite de temps parce
que sinon sur l'échiquier attention
quand même pourquoi il a donné son pion
a
qui va réussir à faire ça ça pour ces
trois tours à 3 je pensais un choix qui
me paraît assez surprenant quand même
l'impression qu'il se met un peu dans
les problèmes tout seul ça arrive ici
non
le dangereux aussi parfois 6 en fait il
veut se venger sur le pion G2 manière
tour à deux sûrement et essayer d'aller
manger à tour Eiffel d'avoir précis qui
bloque complètement les blancs la tour
bouge bleue là c'est un zigzangle un
quasiment
on range 3 ok rouage 7 peut-être avec G5
qui est toujours mal au temps tout ça
Ding ballottant moi ça me fait peur
ça me fait peur
mais de l'autre côté dès qu'il mange à 5
après la finale peut être un peu dur
et fuite qui peut être embêtant
que le petit tour de manège ouais
ce segment
stuffs pour ce premier segment
pourquoi moi j'ai 4 ans et demi ici il y
a 4 4 parce que j'ai pas été mis à jour
non je crois qu'on leur manque
donc du coup prochain segment en trois
plus une heure de propulsion et ensuite
suivi de une demi-heure de une plus une
donc est-ce que tu veux partir en pause
Samy
enfin une petite pause de de 3 minutes
et on revient tout de suite en compagnie
Samy pour Tim enfin pour commencer du
coup ce deuxième set en 3 + une donc à
tout de suite au chocolat dans un encore
mieux à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour
et sa reine qui a quitté a quitté la
pièce
comment ça va se jouer dans ce match en
tout cas intéressant pour l'instant un
4,5 honnêtement
à part le facteur connexion de
diminueren il a l'air plus fort sur
l'échiquier
on a digne qui est plus fort mais
Sarine qui qui est plus rapide et
très inspiré en tout cas dans ce match
ça ça promet alors moi j'ai toujours
quand même garder garder mon petit
chouchou ligne que j'aime beaucoup
et on va voir un petit peu ce qui ce qui
fait entre les gens sont pas encore
installés mais ils vont arriver
il pensait qu'il y aura encore une
partie en 5 + une sauf que c'est terminé
oh on a pas vu ce qu'il mangeait
on va avoir une deuxième chance
peut-être des fraises je crois qu'il
mange des fraises
est-ce que c'est la saison des fraises
en Chine en France en France Espagne pas
trop je crois
[Musique]
les fraises je suis un grand mangeur de
fraises
j'ai cliqué et le sablier qui s'occupe
du timer c'est logique
il est toujours là pour ce timer sablier
on devrait on devrait le faire un petit
contrat
je pense
[Musique]
pour que digne ne mange pas de bonbons à
la vidéo
à chaque match il est là pour me
rappeler qu'il faut que je change
c'est ouf
un peu avant de commencer
et alors du coup ce qu'on sait quelle
heure il est un peu chez les joueurs
peut-être pas si tard que je sais pas
est-ce que peut-être comment faire pour
se renseigner à quelle heure fait-il en
Chine et quelle heure fait-il
en Inde pas être marrant à savoir salut
Jacques
bienvenue à toi
quelle heure fait-il en Asie
alors que les joueurs attendent pour
commencer cette partie
bon ça va
ça va
généralement il y a une il y a trois
heures et demie de décalage avec la
France
OK
et en Chine en Chine il faisait nuit
tout à l'heure je crois quand on a
commencé le stream
d'ingly Rennes j'ai vraiment pas la
fenêtre et voilà de faire nuit
nuit de 4h du matin ou nuit de de minuit
un changement d'ouverture
au début j'ai pas vu ce qui s'est passé
E5 le grand courant
il mange le pion
sacrifie il a la perte de fond en
échange alors ça écoute je l'avais
jamais vu cette position
[Musique]
peut-être pour ce match
qui attaque le cavale grand rock waouh
et là je sais pas comment il va
continuer peut-être un petit fou des
quatre pour commencer
pas convaincu comme ça
on a du mal à avancer nos pions à la loi
et que les blancs ou nos fous ta pas
directement sur le roi je la perds de
fou mais j'ai du mal à faire valoir ce
flou blanc
le cavalier va manger des clous viendra
ici donc il est fort et
bah il y a un peu plus après il faut
voir un petit peu en pratique c'est pas
si simple
j'aime bien mais j'aime bien les noirs
[Musique]
qui a du sens
pour le domaine de revenir en Z5 et de
faire tour à H4
[Musique]
c'est moi qui rentre chez moi
c'est moi qui rentre chez moi ok
d'accord j'ai compris
c'est plus compliqué que ce qu'on
pensait
[Musique]
pour forcer les changes et au final
reposait qu'il favorise la taque et
l'activité les noms de plus mais bon le
plus il est ici
[Musique]
je préfère maintenant la tourner
finalement oui c'est pas pour un taquet
mais pour essayer de la jouer plus
positionnée pourquoi pas surtout
maintenant que des trous ont été faits
sur case noire
on va voir aussi un tout c'est
intéressant on vient de changer de
cadence
au niveau du temps comment les joueurs
s'adapte parce qu'ils ont été très lent
globalement jusque là ouais on voit que
accéléré un petit peu la cadence
[Musique]
attention
finalement il y a des compensations pour
le pion bah non plus on a vu il essaie
d'éviter l'échange des des fous pour
avoir tu vois pour garder vraiment une
des possibilités de gain quoi il veut
pas avoir foutu le reposer il faut
vraiment garder des options de gain il a
un peu plus qu'un main au final donc il
est disponible
il y a pas photo
va arriver un jour bref
très bien
alors
intéressant
du coup il va rendre le pion ici
et ce qui va le prendre ça paraîtrait
tu reprends mes 7 tu reprends ces 5
tours C6
point de vue mais j'ai peut-être
j'essaie de faire du tout reprendre à ça
pour mater là-haut avec le fou qui
contrôlerait mais c'est compliqué
mais c'est pas très académique quand
même
trouvé un plan pour les blancs ici non
je vais finir par être mieux
finir par être mieux si tu arrives pas à
manger le pion
ça y est maintenant il faut ramer
cavaliers peut-être en dessin que ce
serait c'est très cool
je sais pas comment il va faire c'est
pas facile de ramener ce cavalier
A5 pardon reste un peu faible c'est pas
si facile pour
les Noirs ils sont obligés de laisser
leur cavaliers en B7 pas non plus
terrible alors
5 soi-même
ça peut permettre comme toutes les
changer et la calculer sa ring ici
certainement c'est le coup critique
aussi reculer tout simplement si je veux
garder la tension les pièces
je pense qu'il va reculer parce que ça a
l'air quand même de changer pas mal de
pièces de rendre la paire de fou
là
vis-à-vis ah ok alors dangereux tout
recettes ok ben s'activer
tu vas prendre une tournure à très
chaude je pense clairement les trois
résultats
[Musique]
tours qui va être joué il faut s'activer
il faut faire des choses et finalement
le reposer c'est tout ouais
on a l'occasion il le fera pas parce que
il y a le fond en l'air et c'est en tout
cas un coup possible il rend les pions
il y a un pétrole en l'air qui va être
mangé et T4 qui tombe et un pion de plus
du coup pour le noir toujours mais
mais non il y a pas de réseau de matin
je pense pas toujours le roi qui va
venir ici mais le pion qui va être perdu
après fou 7 donc on va sûrement manger
C4 en échange mais bon depuis un contrat
fut pu reposer je vois mal comment les
Noirs pourraient gagner ici faut juste
pas jouer le foot et 6 qui aurait perdu
à cause de tour des quatre échecs
maintenant
sacrément difficile à passer ça va faire
nul dans les prochains coups
je t'attends de la proposition qui va
arriver
tout F6 et ça va être nul
dans un instant il a même poussé le pion
pour rendre le fou voilà
deuxième nulle du match et oui
après une première heure de jeu vraiment
sanglante
moi c'était pas une nulle carrément il y
a quand même pas mal d'actions
aurait pu tourner dans les deux sens
c'est parti donc en fait il y a plein de
choses c'était assez cool
alors B3 il veut tout démolir des cinq
C4 thématique en sa position
de Gambetta accepter
donc pour les blancs mais on voit mais
tout de suite une grosse pression sur
les pions noirs
et d'ailleurs le pion qui va qui va être
récupéré tout de suite
pour les blancs alors dame prend des
quatre c'est pas possible c'est tout
j'imagine je connais pas trop la théorie
mais
de réfléchir donc ça doit jouer un peu
des petites lignes des petites idées pas
forcément des choses standard sur lequel
ils peuvent débiter en automatiquement
à la reine VM il joue mercredi soir à
19h à fifty breaker
parce qu'au final le jeu vaut la
chandelle
[Musique]
à côté surpris le problème c'est pas non
plus te permettre de faire n'importe
quoi après il y a un crémant ça te
permet quand même de pouvoir finir la
partie donc il faut pas non plus faire
trop n'importe quoi non plus donc
tic tac tic tac elle s'habiller qui est
là moi je pourrais dire aussi ding dong
ding dong
ne le fera pas
le centre pour les blancs clairement
mais
une sensation passer loyer dans la
colonne à
pression sur le pion des quatre aussi
qui est pas non plus négligeable mais
quand même
pas mal le pion à 5 qui est quand même
bloqué comme dirait un cavalier Blokker
c'est la meilleure pièce pour bloquer
des pions
les pions à passer
au bord ça m'encourant sur une colonne
comme ça
donc l'ouverture que c'est quand même
plutôt bien passé pour les blancs mais
voilà 300 pas non plus de quoi être trop
s'inquiéter pour Sarine non
[Musique]
ça va être dessin donc gratter le four
et du coup tu réponds comment à 7
questions à vous deux pour regarder ton
Robin et garder des 5 en ce moment
pas envie d'échanger pour pas donner un
temps de développement gratuit aux
cavalier en fait faut prendre je marche
je sais même pas sûr de faire cavalier
prend je pensais pas tout reprend
ok je pensais à tourbéen qui avait les
bêtises qui était une idée et je suis
pas sûr tiens fou à deux il joue mon
idée en fait ça reste quand même une
idée qu'on peut faire souvent et du coup
je voulais garder en fait les options de
faire trop bien pour chaque fois je
préfère
contre la case B6 justement peut-être
des fois aller en F6 pour mettre un peu
de pression sur les pions centraux
et tourbillon peut-être qu'il devrait
adjoint sauf ou auquel tu pensais c'est
la dernière pièce blanche qui n'est pas
vraiment en jeu ma tour bien mais est-ce
qu'il y a pas d'âme à trois qui peut
poser problème au foie à deux quand même
parce que je veux quand même pousser
j'ai fait à deux c'est aussi pour pour
la colonne
et se créer un pion passé donc c'est pas
encore un pion qui pourra
[Musique]
cavaliers plutôt
il a
deux et pas fou
et du coup on va peut-être avoir un
autre cavalier bloqueur mais si elle est
noir on décide cette fois-ci qui sera
bien placé ce cavalier on décide il fera
le but du cavalier bloqueur en fait
c'est plus cavalier il bloque un pion si
vous voulez un purpassé qui qui peut
être dangereux et en fait le cavalier
ici il va contrôler et attaquer des
pièces ou des pions qui peuvent
éventuellement aussi défendre ce pion de
5 c'est pour cette raison là que
cavalier en plus et bien c'est le
meilleur bloqueur
en plus il est plus difficilement
attaquable
donc cavaler bloqueur là pour venir ici
et là il y a quand même un vis-à-vis
donc qu'est-ce qu'on a vraiment envie de
le cavaler des six
mois
5 ouais
en fait j'ai quand même pas mal de jeux
et j'arrive vite enfin 34 ans
c'est le moment charnière de la partie
tu fais quelques coups précis ça va
aller et sinon tu peux être en danger
ouais on sort ça arrive n'a plus 15
secondes surtout attention il met sa
position de bloqueur ce qui est pas
forcément ce qu'on voulait c'est parce
qu'on voulait de base c'est pas très
cohérent par rapport à ce qui vient de
faire avec son cavalier F5 il se fait
déloger la dame
pour virer ce cavalier et essayer de
pousser ce pion jusqu'à une case
protégée il fait des six directs
quand même plus dangereux que le pion a
pour l'instant donc c'est ce qui donne
très bien joué garde la carte de 7 avec
le fou qui va aussi venir en cas de
[ __ ] ça risque au bord de tomber ici
il y avait il faut prendre un B5 aussi
qui était possible
je pense il y a pas de cavaluer le 6
derrière qui va qui risque d'arriver un
jour c'est la seule façon de ne pas
gagner la partie abandon
dans les positions dangers de mieux
jouer mais on va voir on va voir avec ce
facteur temps encore une fois qui peut
tout inverser à tout moment ça reste au
niveau du score alors Ding qui prend
l'avantage dans ce match avec 6 à 5
du monde digne s'il vous plaît
j'ai pas la date ici alors peut-être que
son avril stuff mais j'ai pas la date
exacte on va pouvoir trouver je pense
vous marquer world champion
vous devrez pouvoir le trouver
mais c'est dans quand même quelques mois
maintenant j'ai pas encore
ça se rapproche ça fera bizarre de voir
un match en carrière donc
du coup
en puissance il a l'expérience du coup
d'un match que diminua pas
aussi le fait de préparer un match
championnat du monde ça te force à
travailler comme un fou quoi
le fait de enfin là mes pauvres je pense
qu'au niveau du répertoire il est
vraiment préparé très bien préparé sur
plein de lignes un gros travail qui
n'avait pas fait à l'époque et je sais
pas ce que j'avais vu ça ou l'interview
de je sais plus qui disait qu'en fait le
fait de préparer le chocolat du monde ça
te forcer en fait à être juste trop bien
préparé en fait
c'est sûr
l'équipe adverse elle est là pour
chercher les trous dans ton répertoire
et
[Musique]
par rapport à ce qui nous habitué
par contre de prendre une petite leçon
dans leur match d'ailleurs avec Maxime
de speechesse malgré tout rapide mais
voilà c'est quand même un autre un autre
jeu après je suis pas sûr que mes pots
ont envie de te montrer ses prepas
absolu ça c'est pas la priorité voilà
mais bon oui c'est un Romain ça peut
Maxime il est clairement pas
derrière quand on parle de de blitz de
de speechers c'était à peu près moi je
pense que c'était clairement équivalent
un smack à 55 ans je pense que ce match
je vais vraiment sur la forme des
joueurs aussi
Maxime qui va partir sur un nouveau
cycle il a arrêté de travailler avec
Etienne Macron
pour essayer de trouver un nouveau
souffle dans sa carrière
que bien sûr se qualifier pour les
prochains candidats ça très important
pour lui parce que malgré tout comme les
autres joueurs de génération commence à
vieillard un petit peu donc il a pu tant
d'années que ça potentiel au top top
niveau pour en tout cas lutter pour le
meilleur place mondiales donc c'est
maintenant quoi c'est maintenant qu'il
faut
réussir à se remettre
dans le bon sens on va dire
et ben non justement enfin je sais pas
ça c'est des infos je trouve sur un
nouvel équipier
je ne sais pas trop non plus pour
l'instant Fontenoy
ça pas encore beaucoup filtré alors je
pensais à un coup bizarre à sa vie tu
vas pas aimer mais je pense à toi
en fait je pensais à foi
des 5 faut prendre des 5 cavaliers
mais j'imagine que tu vas pouvoir te
défendre mais c'est pas c'est simple
[Musique]
ou le tamaris
Achille du coup d'accord
il va essayer de récupérer
pas exactement comment il veut faire
marcher le truc
il va y avoir tout reprend il faut
prendre qui attaque là et c'est ce qui
avait les bougies
il a le temps de trouver une défense
[Musique]
dans la colonne et après après pouvoir
potentiellement bouger à temps ou à quoi
on va se retrouver avec deux pièces pour
la tour du coup je trouve probablement
vous avez vu hein
intéressant
à la pendule et qui
et qui tilte un peu je pense il a
complètement raté et sur F6 il se passe
quoi Samy la fille
et tout va vite
très joli
c'est le bon coup il a
joli
dévier la pièce des problèmes sur la 8e
rangée et avec deux secondes
qui a raté quelque chose je crois
attention plus qu'une seconde
il faut que je vide là
proche de tomber
il a plus de temps malheureusement il a
plus tendu tout
ranger deux derrière
complètement craqué
chez Sarine
une fin de partie
un commentaire là des
erreurs des deux côtés donc c'était très
compliqué les deux rois faibles
c'est celui qui ferait la dernière
erreur qui perdrait ici et c'est ça donc
à craquer finalement
mais c'était pas très propre
alors j'ai trois
ça fait 7,5 qui a été menée 4 2 en vous
le rappelle qui a commencé sa remontée
par un cadeau
de faire play de farine pour revenir à 4
3 et derrière
il commence un petit peu à prendre le
dessus
c'est aller blanc quelle occasion
peut-être d'enfoncer le clou là le
joueur chinois
ça commencera à faire une belle avance
tout
non c'est clair
après après je vais pas trop de soucis
encore pour Sarine qui qui a ambulette
quand même
essentiel je l'ai bien essentiel
être favori je pense
je suis pas sûr que digne fasse beaucoup
de Bullet chez lui
ils sont tellement fort mais oui ça fait
un peu peur le temps quoi alors
Ulysse en fait tu vois que là dans le
tableau il y a 4 ans et demi quatre et
demi-heure et demi en fait il y a trois
cadences différentes et à chaque fois à
chaque cadence et ben on va additionner
les points qu'on a fait donc pour
l'instant il y a 7,5 pour le genre
chinois digneren contre le joueur indien
Niall Sarine
et on est dans la deuxième portion de 3
+ 1 il reste 35 minutes tu vois en haut
de temps réglementaire et une fois qu'on
arrive à zéro on passera en une plus une
pareil pour additionner les points et il
y aura que 30 minutes de
5 tac on a même peut-être un petit tour
C1 j'aime bien torcer un
un pour attaquer ses 6 et mettre un peu
la pression je pense en tout casse
blanche peut être pas mal
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour arriver à
je pense malin
c'est un peu ce qui manque à peut-être
un peu de fraîcheur
c'est la route vers la retraite
donc
je pense pas que que Sarine va
va regretter son coup de fair-play parce
que il est comme ça
il y a pas de quoi regretter de toute
façon
il est encore une position difficile à
jouer je pense il y en avance
sur les meilleures à chaque fois tours
c'est deux
alors que c'est pas si intuitif ici dans
ce cavalier en E3 qu'un Pione 2 mais
pourtant justement il bloque la colonne
il tape sur des 5 et moi je crois deux
qui est pas ouf elle a une dame
franchement qui prend la colonne c'est
qui empêche tous les tours c'est vite
tous les trucs comme ça
est-ce qu'un coup alors c'est pas sûr
mais un même comme fou c'est lui qui
peut être une possibilité pour
rentrer sur la colonne C mais je suis
pas sûr quand même hein
je suis pas sûr que c'est quand même
parce qu'au final le foot B7 est quand
même
un tout mauvais alors foutez cette quand
même avec une possibilité
X6
qui vont commencer à entrer en ligne de
compte faire attention avec les Blancs
je sais pas si c'était valide qui sur ça
vous pouvez venir là tu vois
je sais pas trop
H3 j'aime bien dans l'idée mais là
j'aime pas trop trop de voir [ __ ]
madame dame B3 pour penser que sur
cavalucate je peux manger des cinq
mais ce que j'aime pas trop dans ce café
dim sur le dernier coup je te montre
c'est ça c'est
j'ai pas compris
ce qui est pas idiot parce qu'après il
faut prendre deux ben il y a ça en l'air
il y a ça en l'air pourquoi il réfléchit
maintenant c'est les noirs qui
réfléchissent
on va essayer de manger à 2 pour se
créer un passé
un peu du mal à comprendre quand même
son son coup parce que je pense qu'il
prend beaucoup de risques au final là on
voit maintenant qu'il est qu'il est pas
très bien alors tu sens que la position
elle a tourné quoi
à toutes les cartes en main pour revenir
à un point de son adversaire
ouais moi j'aime bien tout tourbé et
tout pour essayer de de pousser à sa
malheur à être le plus simple
alors attention le pion dessin quand
même on s'en fout parce qu'on va manger
deux derrière mais c'est ça pour
l'instant je veux pas peur parce que je
sais que tu manges à la fin je pourrais
manger aux deux et je pense franchement
à deux une découverte quand même sur ta
tour à 8 c'est vrai qu'il va tout va
vite aussi
de farine on s'enlève de
du vis-à-vis de la du Fou G2
et du coup si tu prends des cinq
maintenant je prends je prends et je
prends en E2 je prends en B2 et puis je
pousse les pieds quoi c'est l'autoroute
pour les pions après
même si tu prends je m'en fous voilà si
tu prends je m'en fous si tu prends là
derrière parce que
ça va tout seul
alors faut prendre souper attention
quand on va tout prendre
d'ailleurs il fait tomber vite il s'en
fout il veut pas laisser ton projet 6
avec le fou il y avait un vis-à-vis avec
le roi ne coûte trop ranger ses c'était
une menace
qui est mal au temps
à trois voilà le pion qui part
normalement ça va être dur hein
pour pour Ding cette partie
une seconde et qui va
quand même ça m'étonne mais
il tente
[Musique]
encore un petit pause de trois quatre
minutes avant de reprendre la deuxième
portion de Blitz donc avec Ding qui est
rattrapé d'un point par niassarine donc
7,6 pour l'instant au bout de deux
heures de jeu Samy
c'est vraiment hyper serré un match qui
est très difficile de deviner l'issue
donc on a encore une heure de jeu on a
encore une demi-heure deux blites en
trop puissant ce qui nous fait à peu
près je pense
4-5 parties
avec ensuite une demi-heure de de Bullet
en une plus une donc on va partir en
pause 3 minutes et on vous dit à tout de
suite
pour le dénouement de ce set en 3 plus
une
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes de retour tandis que la
deuxième portion je sais pas les caméras
je ne comprends pas pourquoi les caméras
sont pas là
tu cherches les caméras chez de voir ce
qui se passe sur les chéquiers et on va
commencer par un cavalier F3 pour farine
ou selon le Bullet se rapprocher et
c'est une constante en général dans les
matchs au fur et à mesure qu'on
s'arrange de la fin et je vous de plus
en plus de systèmes avec des fiansketto
et beaucoup moins de théorie
je comprends pas [ __ ] les caméras
un setup très solide au centre avec un
triangle sur casse blanche B7 c'est 6 D5
E6 très dur à casser contre le fou des
blancs keto le Fuji de
qui peut s'ouvrir à tout moment ou
d'ailleurs que la dame blanche je viens
de s'écarter du vis-à-vis avec le fou
des joueurs qui ont un petit peu
accéléré là on se débute
il faut demander la scène d'un Lupin de
dire
sont complètement
[Musique]
complètement déréglé en fait
trop bizarre tour de magie et pourtant
pourtant je n'avais rien fait je suis
absolument rien faire alors les blancs
qui peuvent manger au FC mais c'est pas
forcément dérangeant de
se défaire à structure de pion côté noir
ici
on aurait pas eu à craindre grand chose
pour notre roi on aurait eu la paire de
fou c'est pour ça bien sûr que les que
les Blancs donc décidé de pas manger et
de garder leur puissante batterie dans
la grande diagonale noire la dame et le
fou qui tape même si pour l'instant
c'est bien défendu par le fouet
dans des noirs
les deux joueurs il y a pas eu
d'échanges de pions encore donc les deux
joueurs qui ont un petit peu de mal pour
l'instant à trouver des ouvertures des
brèches dans la position
et la Tour Blanche qui bascule à la dame
toutes les pièces blanches sont
concentrées sur cette dame peut-être
voilà ça va s'échanger finalement
un moment donné
dans cette partie
je sais pas si sur
les caméras elle marchent
[Musique]
mais je les vois en fait ils sont très
très bien mais juste sur mon Obs elles
sont comme si c'est invisible
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé alors la
dame noire qui a la machine arrière et
les blancs comme annoncé qui ont poussé
les cinq regardez encore une fois je
vous ai annoncé au tout début de cette
partie que avec les noirs on avait cette
triangle de pion sur casse blanche pour
lutter contre le fou G2 et les blancs
qu'elle a été leur stratégie ben c'est
de taper à la base de cette chaîne de
pion mettre la pression pour essayer
d'ouvrir leurs fous coûte que coûte
c'est vraiment l'enjeu pour l'instant de
cette partie
mais ça pourrait aboutir à une
liquidation imaginons les blancs
prennent en C6 et noir reprennent
derrière on échange en dessin
avec une position où l'aile d'arbre en
termes de pion aurait juste disparu
peut-être ce qui va se passer ben prend
ce système était joué dame c'est le donc
position je pense quand même très
équilibrée alors là est-ce que les dents
ils peuvent manger dans ces quatre
je pense pas parce qu'il y a le cavalier
qui reprendrait
peut-être juste jouer le tour B8 ici
pour maintenir les statuts avec les deux
les quatre tours qui se regarderaient
dans le coin des yeux
et toutes les pièces qui se neutralisent
les unes des autres je trouve je vois
que les caméras sont revenus
ok on a une position vraiment équilibrée
et encore du temps les sites de doubler
les tourne ici mais ça aurait pas posé
de problème outre mesure dans les
cahiers qui peut bondir on se single la
dame va sûrement revenir en C2 au moins
qu'il voit il la met au C2
j'ai du mal ici avoir deux jours à faire
la différence dans cette position
peut-être la partie la plus équilibrée
depuis le début de ce match où il y a eu
beaucoup de chaos techniques
et exactement lithium
70 les doigts ils veulent pas d'un pion
isoléon C6 donc des Français 4 serait
clairement une erreur ici
alors certes on a le fond achète qui
tape sur ceux qui ont des trois et sur
la date mais donc les blancs peuvent
reprendre avec le cavalier on s'éclate
ce n'est pas intéressant d'échanger
pour ça faudrait remettre une pression
sur ce pion C4 mais ça a l'air pas
évident
tout le monde va peut-être y avoir du
tout ravi de ça paraît très logique pour
échanger les pièces voilà
tour à deux je pense que
il peut manger si il veut c'est pas
dramatique de laisser la colonne a
pas obligé il peut juste attendre ici
pas trop comment les deux camps peuvent
progresser tout
autant de tes réglages c'est bon j'ai
terminé ok bah regarde on a une position
très très équilibrée très solide ok bon
après la position solide comme ça
avec un statu quo et peu de temps la
pendule je pense que de manière générale
ça va être l'avantagé Sarine qui farine
lui dans le match depuis le début n'est
pas vraiment
à la recherche de meilleur coup à chaque
fois il essaye plutôt de jouer les
meilleurs coups pratiques au vu du match
alors que ces adversaires souvent comme
une grille ou comme comme Ding ou même
d'autres joueurs et Ben sont plutôt à la
recherche de la vérité Samy ils sont
plus perfectionnistes en termes de style
très pratique et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il excelle sur les tombes
dans les Tombois sur Internet dans ces
cas on sera rapide pour l'instant il a
donc un peu de mal à confirmer même si
elle est encore jeune bien sûr il a 18
ans vous le rappelle mais il a un peu de
mal à confirmer au top niveau
par rapport par exemple
à d'autres joueurs indiens sa génération
comme on pense bien sûr à vous cache qui
lui a déjà largement dépassé en termes
de vélo alors qu'il est plus jeune il
est en avance pourtant sur toute la
génération
[Musique]
il se fait rattraper après prendre lui
pour le coup il joue moins en fait il
joue beaucoup plus de tournois 45 tout
ça
et en partie lente il a joué beaucoup
moins mais à chaque fois qu'il joue il
prend des points et là il est à 200680
et quand même pas loin 2016 mais ça rime
pareil ils ont même élo je pense avec
c'est quand même plus compliqué
et ce style de jeu donc pratique au
classique ou on recherche comme
davantage à vérité effectivement F6
c'était pour jouer F7 et vous avez pu
voir là ça allait très vite mais tous
ces simplifié vous n'avez parlé avant
l'elda m'a disparu les pièces lourdes
ont disparu là maintenant ils ont plus
qu'à échanger les dernières pièces les
joueurs et je pense que tout enfin ils
vont tranquillement c'est bien aplanir
la paire de fou chacun la structure est
pareil je pense qu'il y a pas trop de
souci et qu'on va se diriger vers une
nule assez cavalier prend fou prend et
puis les pièces font au fur et à mesure
s'échanger H5 on fixe la structure
digne qui a proposé nul et ça rime qui a
refusé peut-être qu'il a refusé parce
qu'il était joué tellement vite qu'il a
pas eu le temps d'accepter qu'il a pas
vu donc pense pas que
ça reste ça reste égal mais je pense
quand même si rien qui veut jouer pour
la nuit c'est plutôt les noirs et ça a
fait une huile au final
les Noirs étaient mieux je sais pas si
on peut être mieux mais
comme tu l'as dit je pense qu'en fait
juste il a proposé
et du coup ça a de ça a refusé
automatiquement en fait
dans ce match
est toujours plus un pour digne
jusque là
favori même si on se méfie on a déjà
parlé plus tôt mais voilà ça arrive
qu'il y avait dominer guériam Blitz qui
avait de l'avance avant les bullettes
donc on était très confiant sur sa
victoire et c'était complètement remonté
en Bullet même s'il est fini par
arracher la victoire avant des partages
tout comme voilà
que je joue
et Ding il a joué E3 puis E4
le temps donc c'est indienne où en fait
les Noirs ont un temps d'avant ou un
temps d'avance parce que quatre étaient
déjà en deux fois
ok intéressant j'aime bien sa position
donc
dur à jouer parce que la diagonale noire
pourrait s'ouvrir tu vois souvent P4
quand la potion elle est ouverte tant
qu'elle a pas de pions au centre quand
il y a pas en fait quand je dis position
ouverte c'est souvent tu as le 5 contre
D5 et à ce moment là quand je fais ça
qu'il faut d'abord à 5 pour empêcher B4
mais dans cette position
des cartes dur à jouer parce que du coup
le fou noir est ouvert et du coup après
pk je peux avoir des cavaliers aussi ce
qui va ouvrir la position et permettre à
mon fond noir de jouer donc ici du coup
il ajoute les 5 avant même de jouer de
jouer à 5 intéressants et une position
surtout de type étau de maroxy où les
blancs les pions E4 C4
et il y a un pion arrière et noir le
pion D6 qui est un peu la cible
et les Noirs leurs objectifs c'est
essayer de se débarrasser de ce pion
arrière on décide on voit que les pièces
blanches dans la colonne des peuvent
taper dessus peut-être en jouant en
poussant le pion en dessin qu'un jour
qui pourrait provoquer des échanges
massifs et
très souvent sur ce pion en dessin on le
donne on sacrifie pour l'activité
pour la trouver l'activité
est-ce que c'est une possibilité
certainement une après il peut y avoir
tout reprend aussi sur cahier prend
aussi ça pour défendre le pion j'imagine
mais généralement c'est compliqué parce
que ça donne plein de cases même avec
toi qu'à se B5 par exemple souvent il y
a pas mal de choses
c'est vraiment le coup qu'il faut
calculer quasiment à chaque coup qui
peut donner un peu un mal de tête si tu
as beaucoup de choses en prises dans les
colonnes par exemple le fou 3 pour
l'instant il a l'air très loin d'être
attaqué par la tour des Noirs en 8 et
pourtant si ça se liquide au centre des
fois dans des variantes il pourrait se
retrouver sous le feu de cette tour
pareil
du fond noir qui est bouché pour
l'instant mais à tout moment ça peut
s'ouvrir et être un problème tactique
c'est pas nommé le petit fou de toi fou
c'est deux de Digne qui nous permet
d'avoir plus de possibilités notamment
sur la colonne E avec la tour le foot
est mal placé
on vis-à-vis avec la tour adverse depuis
H4 est une option mais tu vois aussi
avec vous
et maintenant ça tape sur F6 aussi un
petit à petit indique qui met la
pression
les noirs qui ont un peu de mal c'est un
moment où on a l'impression que là
finalement les pièces ne rend pas trop
bouger alors que les Blancs peut-être
ils améliorent petit à petit
je pense qu'il va devoir réagir
intéressant parce qu'il faut défendre un
peu tous ces faiblesses là
je ne peux pas jouer
parce que toi j'ai quand même quand même
gênant quoi
ça devient de plus en plus dur je trouve
en pratique c'est marrant tu vois mais
en fait Ding il a joué aux cartes pour
transposer dans une indienne avec un
temps de moi
après c'est un petit peu différent c'est
pas vraiment la principale mais je pense
que qui a fait ça aussi avec raison
parce que peut-être que 10 milliards
n'est pas du tout à l'aise dans ces
positions de stanle peut-être que c'est
ça qu'il avait regardé qu'il avait
préparé il savait que c'était pas
forcément un genre de standard et pour
ça c'est pour ça qu'il a peut-être
d'entrer là-dedans en tout cas
intéressant
de nous démontrer que
par contre dans ce type de position un
peu des taux de maroxil il est très à
l'aise ah oui parce que c'est très
professionnel il fait ce qu'il veut en
fait
tout simplement ce genre de positions
[Musique]
en rond depuis 6 7 coups les Noirs eux
n'ont pas amélioré leur position alors
que les Blancs
deux fois de suite
son visage
il n'a rien laissé paraître en tout cas
si c'est le cas
qui commence un petit peu à se
rapprocher de la zone rouge mais on sait
qu'il est habile avec la souris
une partie de manœuvre
de joueurs qui attendent ce qui se
tourne autour
des pièces qui vont reviennent en
arrière en avant mais dans d'autres
manœuvre c'est généralement les blancs
qui sont bien assez positions avec F5
qui va arriver F4 qui est parti veut
jouer F5 comme tu l'as montré peut-être
veut commencer à percer en F5 attention
que je donne des cases noires ici
peut-être 5 G5 ça peut arranger les
choses quand même pour les Noirs donc
attention quand même ici
F5 c'était surtout qu'en qualité en E6
mais il le joue quand même il y va c'est
ce qu'il a fait je pense pas mais
je pense pas quand même parce que les
cases noires sont trop faibles
je suis pas du tout fan de ce qu'il
vient de faire
si la pâte si bien préparé avec ça parce
que son cavalier en E2 est mal placé
ils ont 10 secondes chacun
alors qu'il y a encore toutes les pièces
encore une fois ou pas
comment voir si le bonnet time sourit
une nouvelle fois à sa rime qui a
l'occasion de revenir en hauteur si ça
tourne sa faveur
quelques secondes
ça va être très très vite
on dirait qu'il a pris l'initiative à le
joueur indien il veut jouer G4 attention
le roi blanc qui peut se retrouver dans
les courants d'airstoof
ça m'apprendra H3
c'est le pion qui tombe attention
fourchette aussi
mais il a pu il a joué plein de quoi une
seconde
[Musique]
je sais ce que tu aurais joué tu aurais
joué foutais en espérant un dame prend
ses deux premières
comment tu me connais trop
ça ne serait pas passé contre moi tout
de suite
j'ai un beau clip d'ailleurs qui
témoigne de ce petit
des fois à la fin plutôt que
d'abandonner vous pouvez abandonner le
coup d'après si ça marche pas c'est pas
très propre mais pas très propre c'est
bonne gare cette bonne guerre mais
ça j'ai laissé marcher plusieurs fois
quand même je l'ai une fois en string ou
j'ai pu le montrer j'ai un beau petit
clip dessus mais sinon c'est vrai que
dans ma carrière de Jean de Bullet je
l'ai placé plusieurs fois
classique de tout bulletistes accompli
le but quand de l'angulette c'est quand
même d'être le plus sale possible donc
en vrai c'est le jeu et c'est pas d'un
cas qui nous contredira
bles alors que moi j'abandonne pas
encore moi je fais encore un petit coup
et du coup c'est légalisation hein le
smash finalement les deux joueurs ont
l'impression
et il reste encore 12 minutes dans ce
match
deux ou trois deux ou trois parties
encore peut-être dans cette canon et
encore et encore une voire deux
normalement sauf si ça arrive à abonne
son jouet
mais je doute
les Blancs étaient beaucoup mieux dans
la partie à l'exterson et puis et puis
une fois que
une fois que la position s'est ouverte
et que
je pense Ding a joué F5 ça c'est un peu
un petit peu transformé je pense c'est
NiAl Sarine qui prenait le dessus à ce
moment-là ça a commencé à tourner à
partir de ce F5 ah sur le badge
globalement
je sais pas qu'est-ce que c'était les
pronoms amis
je sais que ça arrive était côté favori
contre guéri
je vais voir si je sais pas exactement
s'il y avait des j'ai pas reçu
généralement je la recevais pour les
pour les 8e là je l'ai pas reçu dans le
mais moi en France quand même favoris
[Musique]
la flemme je pense elle est dommage
d'hier ce décalage horaire c'était dur
pour
en plus on a reçu les on a reçu les
matchs hier pendant la fin du match des
Garou
et sur le papier je pense que c'était
digne légèrement favori parce qu'on sait
que par exemple voilà il a déjà
failli battre Nakamura dans ce format
donc c'est quand même pas rien
mais
on sait que ça rime des demi-finalistes
déjà et qui est très très dangereux que
je joue très vite donc
je sais pas quelque chose comme ça mais
pas non plus un gros avantage
et le scénario d'ailleurs donne raison à
quel point c'est très très équilibré
pour l'instant c'est hyper compliqué
c'est vraiment égal de partout
et dis-moi ça voilà qu'il a un jeu plus
mur et plus propre mais que il pêche un
petit peu
dans les dans le bon état il y en a
plusieurs reprises
qui va reprendre l'avantage ici c'est
une partie quand même importante après
l'égalisation de Sarine qui peut
enchaîner une troisième victoire
d'affilée peut-être il allait blanc il a
une position
intéressante alors le problème de H5 qui
s'y souffle c'est que tu peux Toto
enfermer la dame quoi quand les Noirs
un risque qu'elle sorte plus
donc après faut voir si le temps
d'arriver avec mon cavalier ou faire des
trucs parce que quand même des choses
mais à chaque c'est un coup qu'il faut
faire
il faut être sûr avoir de le faire
responsable voilà donc du coup il le
fera au moment où il pensera que ce sera
le bon moment
pour l'instant il y a ça en l'air on va
piloter fermer jouer un cahier de projet
5 s'il arrive à le faire marcher aussi
pour ça il aurait besoin d'une tour dans
la colonne des quoi par exemple
donc ouais tu as raison on peut supposer
ici que dingue va défendre le 6
j'ai 5 cavaliers
ici avec ça en l'air aussi intéressant
c'est quand même trois pions avec en
plus le roi noir qui est pas
[Musique]
très bien
défendu
intéressant bonne soirée mala bon
courage avec ton chapiteau
merci à ta femme je pense et salut
fin de match on se rapproche de nouveau
parfaite dans ce match
de partager
et donc finalement il a mis le cavalier
en B7 stuff un cours n'est pas trop
envisagé pour défendre c'est pas la
première fois qu'il y a un cavalier en
B7 un peu bizarre qu'un rôle défensif
mais
c'est quand même la base ou la position
quand même hein il veut essayer de
défendre son roi
il faut pas oublier cette roi qui
pourrait être un moment donné une cible
aussi
ce retour là j'ai des fois du cavalier
C5 qui peut arriver même si à tour des 6
il faut faire attention mais c'est pas
si simple on devrait garder ses pions
ses pions c'est trop solide il y a 11
secondes pour ça rime contre 30 pour
pour dingly Rennes
des prolongations alors aussi comme
Croatie Brésil apparemment d'après notre
réexverson
qui a un deuil j'ai l'impression sur les
deux événements en même temps
très très chaud encore une fois à chaque
fois c'est positions de partout cavaler
des cinq peut-être quand même pour
changer les pièces c'est toujours du 3
résultats à chaque fois F5 pour
solidifier voilà
ok
intéressant ça va pas ça doit pas
marcher
à demain c'est la seule case pour faire
échec et attention oh qui peut arriver
ça va être fini peut-être tout refaire
aussi il y a pas de perpète
je pensais qu'il avait abandonné
est-ce que c'est sa connexion encore une
fois c'est terrible
je sais pas mais là c'était terminé ça
arrive aurait pu abandonner le coup
d'après quoi
[Musique]
en plus tu sais pas si juste il est
tombé parce que bah il était trop long
en fait aussi ça collection c'est dur de
savoir
ça fait trois effets de suite et là
ça va un peu peur pour le Bullet ça fait
un peu peur pour le Bullet parce que
bien favori donc
déjà je pense qu'il est favoris
farine et du coup il reste 4 minutes
c'est sûrement la dernière partie à
cette cadence là
il a pas le choix qui partent
pas tout de cette défaite autant il
avait il avait très très bien joué dans
cette partie
il y avait juste à faire trois F2 tours
F1 c'était mat imparable d'un point les
systèmes d'âme G7
sur son roi il a les mater il a étouffé
c'était l'intox le tourco le 6 mais bon
il s'est passé
ce qui est étonnant c'est de tomber sur
un coup forcé quoi vous pouvez faire
d'habitude
je sais pas à quel point ça cadre ça
sa connexion à jouer un rôle ou pas
là-dedans on sera peut-être dans
l'interview d'après malge
bon donc on a cette dernière partie à
priori en tout cas cette cadence
sur un gambidame
et dingeren donc qui est presque alors
dormir c'est exagéré mais
mais bon quand même
un peu dans les chaussettes
alors fous c'est 5 est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer un fou B5 peut-être
pour essayer de faire [ __ ] 5 et
essayer de l'embrouiller un petit peu il
y a un clouage là et le cavalier
d'ailleurs
il y a la paire de fou
mais bon en pratique ça a l'air quand
même ça a l'air quand même bien pour les
blancs j'ai du mal à croire que que les
Noirs tiennent ça quand même
sur les blancs qui vont qui vont presser
normalement c'est un jeu pour deux
résultats ici
mais attention il y a qu'un du Tour des
deux il y a clairement du contre juin
dame deux malheur à forcer au fou des
trois OK
tous les trois pour empêcher la tour de
venir à chatouiller F2 c'est quand même
c'est un problème ça peut
[Musique]
installer un setup genre à 5 E5 food et
4 ça va être dur d'aller chercher avec
les noirs
là dans ce genre de position on essaie
de faire un peu de construire une
forteresse on va essayer de la
construire la forteresse sur la couleur
ou l'adversaire n'a pas de pièce
spécifique donc à droite
et ensuite on aura plus rien
d'attaquable donc malgré le léger
déficit matériel
complètement joint du coup
ultra agressif pour ouvrir
voilà F5 Sarine qui prend des risques
aussi en fait je pense que par rapport à
ce que tu as dit 5 à 5 moi je mettrai le
fond en D5 si je pouvais essayer de
changer les fous et de rentrer sur casse
blanche je sais pas si ça remarcher du
coup il jouait F5 pour essayer peut-être
de d'ouvrir plus c'est d'essayer de de
créer plus de choses c'est le premier
coup qui me vient à l'esprit mais je
vais vite enlever parce que enfin ça m'a
l'air quand même une prise de risque
il y a tout qui devient faible pourquoi
sur casse blanche il veut il veut pas
jouer juste pour l'année en fait on joue
F5 qui se dit bah je peux aussi
peut-être là il en fait il y a un monde
où ça tourne pour les Noirs F7 tu vois
franchement ça rime qui qui crée des
belles choses dans ce match moi j'ai
bien dame de beaucoup d'avant pour
essayer de d'être plus souple mais même
deux peut-être encore une fois tu aurais
fait pas mal bref problème concret alors
il essaie de contre-attaquer sur Russie
alors là il peut manger des deux mais
même ça a l'air encore mieux non
parce qu'elle apprend je vais manger là
quoi qu'il arrive
la colada du coup maintenant c'est et
la dernière partie c'est la dernière
partie de 3 + 1 OK
je pense qu'il a bien fait de laisser de
faire waif pour activer le roi en fait
au coût d'un pion tu vois il monte le
roi et du coup les doigts
je vois pas comment les noirs peuvent
perdre ça
j'ai l'impression aussi
mais j'ai un peu du mal à défendre cette
tour quand même fuite mais il était des
échecs mais attention que Laura peut
quand même sortir et essayer de trouver
un abri mais vous voyez les Noirs il y a
tout rêve bleu qui peut arriver il y a
des choses qui peuvent arriver et il y a
qu'une seule dame je suis content
je peux pas m'attaquer une dame avec une
seule dame pas faire grand chose et du
coup c'est ce que ça règne essaie de
faire je pense que là la nulle la prend
pas hein ça arrive il a quand même une
chance ou il ne peut pas perdre il y a
pas mal fou qui défend
mais ça arrive de commencer le Bullet
avec plus 1 c'est pas mal quand même
il aurait signé avant le match ça c'est
sûr pour il y a pas de doute mais
maintenant est-ce qu'il peut essayer de
la jouer ou pas est-ce qu'il va prendre
est-ce qu'il va prendre la nul ah il
laisse la jouer il jouera ici il peut
pas la perdre normalement
si c'est pas l'idiot
de la perdition faut vraiment en blender
une pièce pour la perdre avec le noir
parce que comme tu as dit une dame toute
seule ne peut rien faire à part des
échecs et le Roi Lion pourra jamais
aller la soutenir puisque il y a ce pion
E3 dont on doit s'occuper
donc du coup moi j'ai plus d'options
quand même avec les noirs
de passer cacher je mets tout recettes
aussi ce qui peut prendre en compte ça
rien c'est qu'on a vu un dingue craquer
pas mal de fois et pas beaucoup de temps
oui en plus il met la pression et c'est
pas le meilleur joueur de Bullet
d'inglin donc avec 6 secondes à la
pendule
il joue lentement en fait cette position
il aurait dû faire plein d'échecs très
vite et on voit que le Pione il va jouer
ou deux là attention que maintenant le
tout est défendu chez les Noirs
7 et le tour ici attention placé chaud
j'ai encore échec ça il faut que je vide
là il faut que je trouve
pour pour Ding ah il a peut-être réussi
à retrouver l'échecs sur casse blanche
mais il y a G6
blanche enfin de faire des échecs c'est
ça donc là du coup Sarine qui mène de
deux points marqué 18 et demi non je
crois qu'il y a une faute frappe voilà 9
et demi
[Musique]
pour la victoire finale il prend une
belle option et déjà comme Bullet je
pense que les favoris Sarine alors en
plus la deux points d'avant je pense que
le match est va être difficile cette
fois le match pour Ding donc après on
sait jamais on a on était surpris
plusieurs fois dans les bullets de
certains
on pensait qu'il était beaucoup moins
fort en Bullet que l'adversaire et au
final qu'ils ont fait des super match de
Bullet donc on verra bien en tout cas ce
que Ding peut sortir dans ce Bullet
mais voilà il est vraiment doux au mur
cette fois-ci il a deux points de moins
et il est obligé de réagir maintenant
quoi et dans le dur il est dans le dur
donc fait une petite pause et on vous
revoie d'ici trois quatre minutes le
temps que les joueurs arrivent et qu'on
revienne au dénouement allez à tout de
suite du coup à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on est parti pour cette dernière
portion en une plus une qui commence à
l'instant entre Ding lieren et ni
alsarine donc on avait dit on pensait
avoir un bon avantage pour farine dans
ses bullets on va voir un petit peu ce
que ça donne
un système de Londres
là il va jouer très vite donc les trois
petits rock
et à regarder à quel point il y a un
changement de de rythme dans ce match ça
va tout de suite beaucoup plus vite même
si sur le 5 les blancs prennent un petit
temps ça va bien comment réagir parce
que c'est vrai que
le roi pour avoir des petits problèmes
après la prise dans le 5 la dame qui
reprend qui donne un échec il faudrait
couvrir et reculer avec une pièce
peut-être pas ouf ici
pour les blancs il y a toujours un pion
isolé quand même donc
c'est un jeu un peu avec plusieurs
déséquilibres chacun a ses problèmes
[Musique]
en tout cas digne sauf qu'il joue tout
tempo pour l'instant il a compris que
fallait clairement hausser le ton au
niveau
du temps
comme maintenant par exemple
il est dominant qu'il en gagne une ou
deux pour recoller un petit peu au score
parce que si jamais ça rime sans vol ça
va être très dur dans la tête pour le
joueur chinois il faut il faut qu'il
joue vite peut pas se laisser parce que
c'est mener autant
dans les 10 dernières secondes ça se
passe toujours très mal donc faut qu'il
se garde un petit matelas de sécurité
en tout cas il s'active ici j'aime bien
ce qu'il fait
il est assez fort en dessin qui prend
contrôle de la case de 8 qui empêche du
coup le doublage de Tours pour enfermer
le fou mais il faudrait calculer qui est
éponger 4 ce serait quand même très
risqué qui va attaquer la dame c'est ce
que je pensais au début
c'est 4 attaque la tour ok j'aime bien
car il s'écartes dames bouge mais j'ai
toujours un problème pour venir
contester à cette cette colonne eux
c'est peut-être pas si grave quand même
mais oui pour l'instant ça rime qui a
les choses sous contrôle et on va voir
de toute façon ça va encore une fois se
décider certainement dans le bonnet time
alors il a mangé en C4 qui me paraît un
peu une décision responsable parce que
ce foot était quand même pas mal mais il
faudrait le cavalier ici on peut penser
aussi un petit G4 dames j'ai trop un
jour le fou qui pourrait peut-être être
enfermé
qui pourrait partir pour les noirs pour
essayer de Kevin qui revient qui revient
pour supporter son petit poulain
il a bien fait de pas être dispo
aujourd'hui avec l'anniversaire de sa
fille
Kevin franchement ça m'a écouté pas mal
de Seb ce petit ce petit match
il est capable de créer la surprise de
sublimer dans cette portion de buvette
même si pour l'instant ça se passe pas
très bien cette première partie cette
finale où il vient de perdre un pion
surtout
creuser les cartes pour sa rime de
passer à plus 3
je pense ça va être fait hein je vois
pas trop comment parce que même Sandrine
avec peu de temps la pendu en fait il
est redoutable et franchement moi ici et
les cavaliers qui sont très dangereux
ambulette ça fait des fourchettes de
partout même à ce niveau c'est dur à
gérer surtout n'oubliez pas il y a déjà
pas loin de 3 heures de match donc très
fatigués en Chine on a dit qu'il était
très tard c'est tout ouais il était je
crois deux heures de plus quand
du matin je pense en Chine
romain l'idée à peu près peut-être une
heure ou trois je sais plus mais entre
une heure ou deux différences entre les
deux joueurs
et il est tard chez les deux
oui il s'accroche dans cette finale sont
fous qui tient les cases du cavalier
beaucoup de simplification donc il est
quand même sur le chemin de peut-être
tenir la nul mais travail encore l'eau
ouais travail est long et avec peu de
temps la pendule il peut se passer des
choses tous les pions blancs sont
surcases blanches c'est une bonne chose
je pense peut-être pour Ding qui pourra
toujours essayer de récupérer B3 si
jamais le pion venait à s'avancer
attention en pion F6 est-ce un petit peu
ce cavalier qui est en train de rendre
complètement Fooding il tourne à droite
à gauche et maintenant
je pense c'était dévastateur
effectivement je pense qu'il peut pas
faire grand-chose contre cavalier 5
allez on part sur une sur la même encore
un Gambetta ma cage 6
il fait ça depuis l'autre jour avec avec
Guiri la pas changé c'est pas par ration
pour ce match Sarine c'est maintenant
qu'il faut agir pour dire parce que il a
moins 3 ça commence à être critique il
allait blanc il peut pas se permettre de
perdre une partie
et pour le moral aussi une victoire lui
ferait beaucoup de bien de ce qu'il en
perte d'oxygène depuis depuis une
grosseur ça se passait bien il menait au
score en ce match la première moitié il
avait deux points d'avance et petit à
petit il a commencé à s'essouffler en
fait j'ai l'impression que tu vois
depuis la partie qui l'a perdu autant à
quelques coups du mat et ben il
commençait un petit peu à cette baisse
de régime là chez
une belle position elle a un pion passé
protéger avec le petit cavalue D2 E4 qui
peut être intéressant avec le fou tu
vois le fou qui bloque le pion E4 qui
est pas généralement pas conseillé c'est
plutôt un cavalier qui vient des signes
généralement pour bloquer ce position
mais beaucoup de belles positions que
malheureusement il a souvent pêché à
conclure c'est ça j'aime beaucoup la F5
qui gardent des options avec foudre pour
taper ici et ici
ça a l'air ça a l'air prometteur pour
les bras et il a 50 secondes pour
l'instant il a bien joué au niveau du
temps il a joué vite et peut-être
essayer de
retourner
le 5 qui arrive aussi la position est
quand même avantageuse pour les pour les
blancs c'est clair ça c'est H4 pour
cueillir 5 maintenant je pense que c'est
un petit peu trompé Admiral parce que
jusqu'ici la case H4 était contrôlée et
si qu'elle arrive F5 bah ça a l'air
dévastateur pour le roi noir
coup et digne qui irait 45 secondes à la
pendule est-ce que ce serait pas un
nouveau digly rain qui qui viendrait
jouer à cette fin de match Sami pour le
suspense souffle et là faut porter le
coup de grâce il a toutes ces pièces
cachées
mais faut pas qu'ils sont dorment
qui est une menace aussi
les pièces noires sont toutes passives
il prend des cinq je pense qu'il tente
tout pour le tout alors
des petites fois
depuis le début c'est ce qu'il a sauvé
parfois c'est coup de bluff mais là il
est hors du kiri prend un chien du
fouprou et elle s'est trompé
il a décalé prend H6 avec damla et Emma
et c'est H5 qui a dû rater j'ai en même
temps que lui je comprenais pas pourquoi
ça n'allait pas mais il y a ce H5
qui fait très mal et il était
complètement foutu de cases vous voyez
elle a plus de cases la dame qui avait
l'air juste
on apprend là c'est hyper gagnant
et qu'elle F4 et là ça rime
après avoir fait n'importe quoi il joue
tous les meilleurs coups de
[Musique]
défenseur nombre de pièces blanches qui
a disparu de l'échiquier c'est terrible
il a trois pièces pour la tour
extrêmement vite et là je suis rien et
un miracle dans cette partie c'est ouf
quand même franchement
d'un prof de maths
incroyable incroyable franchement
ambulette Niall Sarine NiAl Sarine qui
est dans le même tableau que que
Nakamura je crois
oui il y a d'autres ouvrez si il gagne
en demi-finale le vainqueur de de
harmonial
ça pourrait faire un beau match quand
même mais Sarine et à rognan farine et
Naka c'est quand même un petit peu le
même
style en moins fort
donc ok intéressant à voir j'ai quand
même cette partie elle sonne de glace de
ce match parce que quand même il avait
tout qui gagné leur voix c'était dur
mais il pouvait prendre un haschiste il
pouvait prendre en G7 il y avait des
menaces de maths et le coup de bluff de
Sarine qui a fonctionné derrière il a
joué tous les coups on a pu voir très
vite avec la joue il a joué tous les
coups de l'ordi tous les coups de
défense après ambulette bon bah on tente
et c'est jamais simple c'est la maison
de conclure il y a peu de temps à pendu
la pression du match il y a plein de
choses qui font que les joueurs peuvent
se tromper
perte de confiance totale puisqu'il
arrive pas à transformer ces positions
gagnantes il y en a eu un paquet
et du coup ça fait douter et seulement
de porter le coup de grâce qui s'en mêle
les pinceaux à chaque fois
peut-être 4 ici de tout ouvrir parce que
ça vaut
ok
il commence à être dans une obligation
il a quatre points de retard il reste 20
minutes il faut commencer à la remontada
la remontada c'est plus permis là de
lâcher des parties comme ça
auclencher peut-être fou aussi ça
j'ai peur de regarder une petite idée
avec des
le four vis-à-vis le cahier de culture
F5 dans tous ces 7 qui a enlevé le flou
de du vis-à-vis ce qui est complètement
normal
quel meilleur position à la sortie de
l'ouverture il est la paire de fou il va
être très fort sur casse blanche
contrairement à ça arrive alors bien sûr
c'est pas écrasant mais positionnons
agréable mais si c'est un professeur
jolie jolie vis-à-vis aussi sur la
diagonale qui attaque le pion
qui joue vite et qui met la pression
F2 pour connecter un peu les pièces sur
15 novembre
ça me fait très peur
il y a un problème sur A2 là c'est bien
joué de la part de Jean
tour à trois et on va manger le pion
donc un pion c'est un pion quand même il
y a encore tour des autres à la fin et
il ne prend pas en fait si je joue trop
compliqué non mais ton échec et te
reprend ses sept en fait ok pour ça
qu'il a il a voulu mais là du coup c'est
foutu
parce que c'est une partie qui dure
longtemps pour un Bullet pour faire nul
et vu le tableau d'affichage c'est pas
du tout profitable
ça fait partie du jeu
je sais pas ce qui va vraiment le faire
longtemps ainsi il a l'air parti pour un
là il peut faire durer cette partie
je sais pas si tu as vu la partie de
Nakamura hier non il y a une partie
comme ça
cette position la même chez la caméra ça
a duré 6 7 minutes
et à chaque fois
donc là en fait la règle pour vous
rappeler c'est la règle des 50 pouces 50
coups sans prise où pousse espion
ça fait nul et là digne qui rigole
et maintenant il a poussé le pion C4 et
maintenant ça recommence il va faire des
coups de roi pendant 2 minutes et
ensuite il va je vais laisser 5 à un
moment donné et ça pourra recommencer
encore pendant 50 cours
une fois que maintenant il faut plus
même si tu peux manger le pion H4 ou C5
il faut pas le manger parce que ça
repartirait encore 50 coups tu gagnes
mais oui ok mais bon
allez allez on y va donc du coup nul qui
arrange pas du tout les affaires de Jean
quand même dans ce dans ce match où il
reste 17 minutes pour monter 4 parties
donc il peut encore remonter mais il
faut commencer à marquer les points dès
maintenant
on peut encore y croire pour Ding mais
là encore 12 minutes enfin cette partie
on peut dire qu'il va rester encore
quand même ouais 4-5 parties je pense
oui oui il peut même en rester plus au
scénario on sait jamais mais donc là il
faut que là il faut qu'il commence
vraiment à mettre les points cela prend
une ou deux ça peut commencer à faire
trembler un peu Sarine et puis il a
surtout il a les positions pour en fait
c'est ça le truc c'est pas comme si il
se faisait dominer dans le jeu non il y
a chaque fois il est il est à deux
doigts il a toujours il a toujours les
positions enfin il est toujours
l'avantage en fait mais ça rime il a de
grandes qualités de défenseur il trouve
vraiment les coups à chaque fois et
très résilients
allez ce serait bien pour le suspense et
même un petit peu pour le mois est-ce
que c'est un peu dur pour dig là il
mérite vu le fond de jeu au monde en
gagner une ou deux pour relancer un peu
le suspense
il y a pas de deuxième match aujourd'hui
Charles hier déjà
un par jour
donc on reprend lundi du coup tu disais
avec la fiche Naka je crois contre
Aronian mardi tu avais le carcène
Caravana et mercredi tu avais
Maxime contre
exactement à chaque fois à 19h 19h pour
les trois matchs lundi mardi mercredi
on sent bon commenté par Kevin Bordy a
priori peut-être avec Fab Libye voir à
Étienne Macron peut-être pour le match
de Maxime ils avaient commenté ensemble
le 8e de finale là tout est pas encore
décidé mais
on verra dans les prochains jours
alors pour B2 a été joué par Sarine qui
[Musique]
qui rentre un petit peu dans la position
blanche attention au fouet F5 qui arrive
aussi il est malin ce soir il fait plein
de petits coups et quand même d'un
processus mais c'est pas sympa
c'est très dangereux elle est un peu au
milieu de tout ça fait peur et Ding qui
prend tout le temps
il peut pas se permettre de faire ça de
faire ça
et franchement digne qu'il se laisse
tomber jusqu'à 3 secondes il faut en
avoir confiance en sa connexion aussi et
moi j'ai pas trop confiance en sa
connexion si tu veux
du jeune Indien ici
s'arrête
voilà il y a un karaté par pardine et
digne qui sort avec une pièce de plus
quand même au final cette partie et
c'est bien allez là normalement
faut qu'il joue vite là
peut se permettre de jouer vite faut
qu'il remonte autant à 5,6 au moins pour
avoir une petite marge elle est tombée
de
foussée 3 et c'est l'autoroute là
c'est simple normalement à lui échapper
je veux pas le poids c'est mais
bon depuis tout à l'heure il a quand
même des problèmes de
Bullet hyper autant tout ça ça fait
plaisir les cahiers C4 à 7 et C5
doit résister le plus longtemps possible
dans ce match aller dans ces 7 c'est
terminé
vraiment le chrono laisse tomber le
format il essaie d'exploiter le format
on peut pas lui reprocher
ils font tout ça de toute façon ça les
règles donc plus que trois parties à
gagner il reste 12 minutes 50
minutes c'est ça j'aime pas perdre et
encore j'avais avec cette victoire il
reprend un petit espoir
pour enchaîné il faut à tout prix
regagner ici avec les noirs
sur sur Sarine franchement
j'aimerais bien tu vois Ding il est trop
gentil il a trop une tête de vampire je
veux le voir gagner
de le voir gagner il y a des gens qui ne
font pas je suis d'accord avec toi fils
il n'a pas beaucoup mais je suis
d'accord après est-ce que le fait de de
profiter du du système qui lui-même est
pas forcément bien fait est-ce que c'est
surtout pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
seulement
on rappelle que que ça arrive a été
extrêmement fierté plutôt dans le match
de ce qui a perdu une partie au temps
certainement à cause de sa connexion
alors qu'il était complètement gagnant
et ça arrive à abandonné dans la foulée
la partie suivante pour lui rendre le
point donc c'est quand même le geste
papa lui reprocher un manque de faire il
abandonné une partie exprès pour rendre
le point l'adversaire parce qu'il avait
gagné par connexion c'est quand même un
beau geste de la part de Sarine c'est
pas un joueur qui est qui est pas faire
play ou au contraire mais après le
système il est comme ça je pense que là
il y a un problème qui est peut-être
plus profond que ça peut-être un jour à
essayer de changer un peu ce système
Samy on en parlait des fois de ces
systèmes
plutôt au lieu de points comme ça qui
est très intéressant donc on verra un
petit peu après ce que tu es comme
propose mais c'est vrai que
c'est ma base de 7 ans qu'on a vu dans
les distribu club qui fonctionne très
bien au terme de suspense mais là cette
partie c'est tout pendant ce temps en
train de mal tourner pour diminueren
puisqu'il déjà il doit concéder une
qualité et ça pourrait être la partie
presque qui offre le match ça arrive un
siga il reprend 4 points d'avance direct
pour essayer de gagner du temps tu vois
il a raison de pas
un peu de scène il a raison de pas
lutter ainsi c'est qu'il est perdu mais
là il reste encore quatre points à
prendre en 10 minutes ça va être je
pense ami trop compliqué je pense
ça a l'air du en mathématiquement après
on rappelle aussi c'est une partie est
lancée alors qu'il reste trois secondes
dans le chrono la partie va jusqu'à son
terme c'est ça lui laisse un tout petit
espoir mais maintenant il doit à tout
prix
et commencer la quatrième c'est ce que
c'est l'objectif qu'il doit avoir en
tête là il a gagné vite c'est-à-dire
qu'il doit il a une minute 02 il va pas
gagner avec deux secondes à la fin il
doit gagner des pensions le moins de
seconde possible ça et en plus ça rien
qui peut arrêter de jouer à tout moment
pour laisser le chrono ton tomber et je
vous garantis qu'à ce niveau là ça rime
il va le faire parce que
il veut se qualifier quoi
et en plus des revenus financiers à
chaque il peut pas réfléchir comme ça 15
secondes ici il faut qu'il joue tout
tempo
bienvenue pour la toute fin de semaine
à avoir choisi son vainqueur
parce que la tune il s'en foutent là à
ce niveau Robert parce que
c'est vos prorata des victoires il y a
un petit un petit bonus
c'est un vrai représente vraiment pas
grand chose pour
et salut HBK non c'est pas une grosse
surprise GB parce que à ce format ça
arrive il est vraiment
très aguerri et il a toujours eu un peu
de problèmes de connexion et pas
toujours très rapide même si il l'a
montré un très bon fond de Joy il a un
petit peu de mal
donc c'est normal je vous dis il était
peut-être légèrement favori mais pas
plus
de souris
pas mal de parties autant avec des
policiers plus que puisque correct et
c'est vrai que c'est un jour dans ce
match des éléments à prendre en compte
et
ça fait vite si tu perds le gagner ça
fait deux points d'un différentiel de
deux points par rapport au scénario donc
tout de suite
ça crée une énorme différence que ça
reste quand même serré
après Naka il est plus fort mais
comme dit que c'est un très très bon
genre d'échec et ben en fait il est
capable de tout si vous voulez si Rex et
problème de connexion de hypnotes etc il
peut vraiment être un candidat très très
dangereux quoi
parce que aux échecs il est bah il est
meilleur en fait que ça arrive les
meilleurs que tous ces gens-là sur la
compréhension du jeu la pureté du jeu
même là sur le match malgré le score il
a quand même globalement mieux jouer aux
échecs
voilà dans les petites phases tactiques
il s'est fait un peu arnaquer plusieurs
fois
après ça rime qui tactiquement il est là
franchement
un match hyper intéressant
il joue sur ses qualités il a bien
raison et c'est en train de lui sourire
il a pas hésité à sacrifier une pièce
pour pas mal de pions
c'est bien joué encore on a perdu
pratique tout parce que même si jamais
dit mais arrive à la gagner cette partie
c'est le moment d'être fait ça va
prendre beaucoup de temps la durée il
est encore 7 minutes pour gagner cette
partie et en gagner encore deux autres
derrière et en lancer une autre ça m'a
l'air dur hein Sami je pense pas qu'il
aura le temps je pense qu'il va il va
manquer de temps même s'il arrive à tout
gagner là ça a l'air compliqué déjà
celle-là il faut la gagner c'est pas
encore sûr
ça va être long pour aller plus vite
même là même là c'est dur je suis
d'accord c'est même pas gagnant là je
pense qu'il a raté les quatre rapidement
il y a trop de pions
à être même peut-être moins bien
maintenant avec du Havre je crois qu'il
va partir F3
qui a fait un petit geste avec la tête
vous avez pu voir ici il le sait que
cette partie elle lui offre son ticket
pour les demi-finale c'est le premier
c'est ça il reste du coup 6 minutes avec
5 parties autant dire que même si c'est
moi qui joue maintenant je ne perdrai
pas le match il y a l'ampleur du désert
c'est ça j'ai vu ça la cape échec il
avait pas de quoi se payer un hot-dog
[Musique]
on le retient donc l'écart de finale
restant c'est lundi
Nakamura contre aronia à 19h mardi 45 €
à 19h et enfin mercredi
Maxime qui clôturera le bal contre sceau
à 19h aussi
et la demi-finale on se trouve
d'ailleurs ça devrait être dans la
foulée
parce que hier en étant encore en 8e de
finale aujourd'hui on se les carre je
pense que là
les enfants va peut-être
je crois que ça va finissait le 16 tu
m'avais dit donc le 16 c'est vendredi
prochain ce qui est prévu pour l'instant
c'est demi-finales
les deux d'ailleurs les deux le 15
décembre donc le jeudi donc c'est
vraiment sonner et la finale vendredi
donc ouais la semaine prochaine ça va
être vraiment
le dédouement ça va être cool de la des
gros nats tu vas voir du Nakamura du
Carlson on va voir qui a rencontré qui
donc tous les matchs se joueront à 19h
par les demi-finales c'est pas mais
l'écart oui en tout cas et encore perdu
chez
Ding sur le match est terminé un match
terminé maintenant donc tous les matchs
seront à 19h donc lundi mardi mercredi
donc lundi on a Naka contre aronia mardi
on aura 45 Caravana et
mercredi pardon on aura mvl so les trois
matchs commentés par par bitstream
qui sera accompagné apparemment de
conduisait de stress sûrement un
fabbling peut-être un Baki
en fait si l'abandonne et ben
je crois que il y a une retenue sur son
salaire
après même par correction bah tu finis
quoi simplement tu vas pas abandonner au
milieu quoi juste c'est fini c'est fini
OK
merci à Flo pour ce message
10000 à rougit au fur et à mesure du
match
il avait il a fait un très très bon une
très bonne moitié de match mais le
deuxième elle a été très difficile
ils peuvent abandonner dans les 10
dernières minutes mais bon
tu es foutu pourquoi pas mais
attendez quand il reste 10 minutes bon
bah tu finis quoi
[Musique]
l'avantage c'était compliqué quoi après
si vraiment là il est juste il bouge les
pièces là c'est qu'il a perdu donc là il
s'en fout un peu je pense mais
il est fatigué il sait qu'il a perdu
donc c'est
donc C4 puis on prend j'ai tout B2 qui
va arriver donc ça rime qui est vraiment
regarde 46 secondes contre 15
franchement il est juste impressionnant
ultra impressionnant Sarine
en plus les jours relâche c'est
maintenant il sait qu'il a gagné donc
autant dire que c'est plus facile
tu as tout le poids le stress qui
ça arrive maintenant il joue plus
facilement parce qu'il sait que ben il
sait que qu'il a gagné debout il y a
plus 13 c'est son jeu et parce que c'est
la fin du match qui l'a perdu donc je
bouge de la pièce il attend sa mort et
donc ça rime qui qui enfonce encore une
fois le clou
ça va être la dernière j'imagine partie
tout ça va être la dernière
et donc C3 du coup le score et l'euro
final quand même on s'attendait pas un
tel écart malgré tout non non bah en
fait quand tu vois
les deux premières heures je te disais
il y a eu
à la première pause en fait une trou du
3 puissance il y avait 4 et demi 4 et
demi et 3 3
et c'était gâté parfaite et elle a et à
partir de la deuxième enfin juste après
la pause après après la première pause 3
+ 1 tu as digne qui a complètement
collab ça qui
est pas une histoire de connexion là sur
le Bullet à l'extraction pour le coup
non juste
trop difficile pour dingueren car
des petites séquences
et puis pour le moral on a pris un coup
en fait je pense avoir laissé trop de
parts gagnants de s'échapper et derrière
c'est dur dans la tête c'est dur
c'est surtout une partie de buette c'est
quoi c'est la deuxième
où était vraiment mais c'était écrasé tu
as plus 10 il avait plein de
possibilités pour gagner
si je pense que vraiment elle a
définitivement enterrée c'est la fin du
temps réglementaire dans ce match du
coup
[Musique]
cette partie c'est la dernière
du match
qui va juste sceller le score est-ce que
dim va atteindre les 10 points
avec une victoire dans ce match c'est
dur franchement amulette Sarine il est
il est vraiment vraiment fort
quelques jours bah après son match que
il pensait que s'il arrivait en Bullet
contre n'importe qui donc un cul avec
deux points de retard
et pourtant hier Naka et ben il a il a
pas très bien joué sa part son Bullet
contre par avion il a parlé pas mal de
parties
et mais bon je pense c'est un peu
l'excès de confiance chez la gare pour
le coup
c'était du c'était assez ouvertures qui
faisait franchement
pas très respectueux pour son adversaire
il a fait tilté de ouf
c'est dur de jouer le compte de
quelqu'un qui vous massacre qui joue que
des ouvertures du style B3 B4 A4 H4
c'est dur j'allais dire ils vont
peut-être finir la répétition mais non
ça arrive il est impitoyable il a pas
répété il était le projet non mais ça
n'a rien à proposer nul
avant tout ça il y a quand même 20
millions de la partie là pour vous
annuler
a refusé
donc bon il veut quand même finir sur
une victoire
quand même à manger ici et c'est pas
simple
c'est pas simple
après un cas comme il fait un peu le
chaud quoi il essaie de manquer de
respect pas forcément là c'est juste non
mais bon tu peux le centre tu peux le
voir un peu il y a pas eu faux F3 qui
était quasiment maths
G4 et G5
incroyable ce match cette cette
pulvérisation angulette 6 et demi à 1 et
demi pour pour
Sarine qui clôt le match du coup à 17 à
9 c'est un bel démonstration ça a mis en
ambulette
c'est beaucoup plus à l'aise avec son
adversaire c'est ça et du coup donc
Sarine qui prend son ticket pour
les premières deux finales contre
Nakamura
[Musique]
mais encore tout à fait donc gros match
en tout cas de Nakamura contre
harmoniaque qui aura lieu du coup lundi
à 19h suivi du match de 45 Carona à 19h
mardi et du match mvl contre sceaux
mercredi à 19h encore tous ces matchs là
sont suivis sur la chaîne c'est ce que
me faire
et commenter par Kevin bandit en
compagnie de peut-être
Macron avec des invités donc ça va être
sympa donc en tout cas merci à tous
d'avoir suivi le stream merci à Samy
dans ce stream
et du coup on vous souhaite bon courage
pour la suite et bon commentaire à Kevin
en tout cas pour la fin de tournoi
donc merci à tous et puis Samy peut-être
un petit mot de la fin merci et bonne
soirée et à bientôt du coup yes à
bientôt